and we are live
uh last word with lord cognito and
evontis on that thursday night fireside
chat
that's as far as i know i remember what
he says after that cognito's not even
here so people are audio be like who's
talking that who's that beautiful voice
that's indistinguishable from uh cognito
yeah um yeah it's just us right now it
seems like he's gonna be joining a
little bit late yes uh so for everybody
listening on audio everybody live in
chat right now uh cognito had some work
stuff come up so he's working on
just some things right now but we have a
ton to talk about so we don't don't want
to leave you guys hanging
so we will get this uh basically this
whole thing started with i got to ask
you like what have you been up to this
week because i got to hear about this i
need some i need some we've had a lot of
news we're going to get to the dusty
news but i got to hear about this
because this tweet went like crazy and i
got to know why so story time
yeah so um i've been i've been super
busy doing reviews and previews this
week my ties all bunched up oh no um
i've been doing super busy doing reviews
and previews this week uh but one of the
reviews that's been on my docket for a
while and i've brought it up on this
podcast a few times is i was supposed to
review uh crossfire x
uh the first person shooter that's sort
of like a uh
counter strike uh counter strike go type
console version that's that's basically
what it's supposed to be like based on
or or inspired by or whatever and um
they didn't give review codes to anyone
no one got review codes and it's not
remedies fault it was the publisher the
publisher was just holding back codes
and they told us in advance like hey uh
codes are going to be coming out pretty
close to release and so we're like all
right i guess we'll just wait and it
turns out that what they meant by pretty
close to release was literally when the
game came out for everyone else that's
when
the game has gone live hey reviewers you
can you can play it now too
yeah they basically sent out the codes
as like a way to be like hey the game's
out now tell everyone that the game is
out and they can start playing it and so
um
i got the game and i i hate getting
games on on the day they come out
because you have to rush you have to do
as much as you can to get your
impressions out obviously i don't try to
i don't rush myself on the review
because i've got to do it right but um i
i you have to get your impressions out
there as soon as possible because
people want to know and
uh
there's not there's a opportunity for
your opinion to be relevant if if you're
if everybody's able to play the game
before you're able to write about it
yeah so um i immediately started playing
and i played like six the first full six
hours that the game was out i played the
game the entire time
and
it is
unbearable it is a that's a that's a
word choice right there i just want to
stop not like mediocre not buggy we've
been through that not unbearable like
it is unbearable it like ev every part
of the game is bad like the
the game modes that they chose to put in
the game are like really really poorly
conceived like they did no play testing
whatsoever the game is super buggy and
unstable even the main menu is buggy the
main menu lags
and like you have to move a cursor
around that's the thing in new world
that had such like went so high in
frames that killed graphics cards you
don't have a problem with this game at
least because it's only going to get
like 17 frames it sounds like dude
everything about it is is bad like like
it's it's unstable the main menu uses a
cursor a tiny little cursor that you
have to move around with a a joystick on
controller
and it's very slow by the way like it it
moves around like this
my brain a little bit
yeah the the shooting mechanics are
awful it's it's one of the
most poorly controlled games i've i've
played in a long time like no matter
what sensitivity setting you choose
it it feels
it feels like
it's like
i don't know how to describe it sloppy
yeah your cursor just kind of slides
around and it's very floaty and weird
um
and uh
it's just it's it's a confusing game i
have no idea how this game came out in
this state it's really just brutal uh
slower than the d2 menu by a lot
by a lot like not even close the game is
crashed on me in the main menu which
which blows my mind if you can't run a
menu i think you probably should delay
your game why do you do you have any
reason why this sounds awful
like give any reason why who
like developer publisher who made
yeah the publisher is um
i'm forgetting the name right now uh
even smile gate smiling is the name of
the publisher and they're the ones that
made the multiplayer the reason i think
it's like this just my theory is the
same reason that uh halo the master
chief collection launched with a lot of
problems specifically in the menu
because they had teams working on
different parts of the game and then
they kind of pushed them all to shut it
all together an interface at the end so
yeah remedy built two campaigns for this
game and then the multiplayer was worked
on separately and the multiplayer has
also two different engines running two
different game types it's got classic
and modern mechanics and so i think
there were just all these teams working
on separate games and then they mashed
it together in one menu and that's why
the menu crashes
other things about it uh
it has one of the most disgusting micro
transaction models ever
oh
we've had launched it launched with like
18 pieces of content to buy and
uh it it has like you know that thing
where you can spend a hundred dollars on
coins and the coins buy you weapons and
the weapons do have gameplay impact oh
so it just breaks everything they make
you stronger in multiplayer uh if you
buy weapons like everything about it is
so bad man it's so bad i i i'm
i'm appalled yeah g-man said isn't
smallgate the same dev that made the
lost ark
are they i gotta look now because i've
played i was like i'll get to that in a
second i played a decent lost art and i
played the beta before and actually
um
that's fun like that's
well done well polished yeah south korea
okay
uh what games
crossfire x lost ark yeah that's okay
that's the same park okay well hey i'm
not saying they're incapable of making a
good game i'm just saying that this one
is like tragically under baked and i'm
i'm really surprised that they
put it live and
it's just it makes me so upset because
it's so obvious that they knew
that this game wasn't ready because they
didn't give out any review copies and
that just it speaks to a lack of
confidence in their own product and also
like a willingness to to
keep information away from the public
until it was already out you know which
i i just think is
such a
it works against you in so many ways man
it
yeah i just i'm really disappointed in
all of this and and how it's gone down
but uh that's what i'm playing i'm gonna
be playing it all weekend and i'll have
my review up probably early next week
but uh
i'm sorry you have to work through uh
the mashed potato soup over there that
you've gotta try and walk through so i
haven't even gotten into the campaigns
which are also bad by the way the
campaigns aren't good see that's
unfortunate because like remedy's
a good developer feels like they're
right remedy is a great developer i
don't think that they have any business
making a modern realistic shooter
military story you're like you know
control third person weird stuff like
yeah yeah
yeah they make really weird games and
they're working on this uh first person
shooter that's got like a very serious
story it's like oh we to stop this
terrorist organization and all the
characters are just so boring uh it yeah
i beat the first campaign last night and
now i'm part way through the uh the
second campaign you play one campaign is
the good guys and another campaign is
the bad guys oh gotta get a little
perspective in there right
yeah right they're completely different
stories but uh and there is some
supernatural stuff to it which i think
is probably remedy probably force that
in there because they that's what they
know how to do right they have to have
some sort of i was like that sounds like
them
yeah it it it has their touch like the
narrator talks just like in alan wake so
they've got kind of that thing but
everything about it the characters are
boring the the voice acting isn't good
the uh
it's just yeah i
i'm so disappointed in this game man i
was actually
i was actually hopeful that this would
be like a a surprise a sleeper hit you
know i thought it would be something
like that but no it's it's really bad
well i'm sorry that's what's taking up
your time i have been playing
a lot of things actually i've been very
busy
um
i am on the final boss in sifu
so i'm literally like
last guy to beaten it
um
that game is interesting because i've
heard
you know i heard like the nines and then
i saw the sixes
and i'm kind of going
i understand some of the sixes and it
was i was listening to uh kind of funny
and they were talking it was timur
tomorrow hussein i may be butchering his
name um
he was talking about like he was ripping
everything critically apart
like
i it felt a bit extreme but it just did
not click with him so it's one of those
where it's like if something doesn't
jive with you you're gonna find
everything wrong with that and it
sounded like it then you have a couple
of the other guys over there just like
game of the year contender and i'm going
i don't know like that is a very
different game but as playing it i can
definitely see it's got
it's got some touches of sakura with
kind of your posture meter where your
blocks and parries and how much you can
withstand and how much the enemies can
withstand
um
but there's one mechanic and this i did
hear described well by somebody is
it's the way you're meant to dodge
and it's not going to be souls where
you're like jumping or stepping or
rolling out of the way it's like a kung
fu like lean or like a bob and weave
situation
and until you learn to lean into that
it's a pain in the butt once you lean
into that and then you figure out okay
now i just have to time the quick bobs
and weaves
then it turns into something like it
feels really good and i was telling you
this before the show like when you get
to the final boss
heads up there's some kung fu involved
but i mean
it gets to feel like an epic you know
end of movie end of kung fu movie back
and forth really fast like punches kicks
parries
like really quick taps and everything
um and then just like the sound like you
the second level's a club the first
one's not too bad you get to the second
level second level is probably going to
be a wall for a lot of people um but
it's got a good club vibe to it just
like the music behind it but the
thematic elements to the levels like say
the second one this won't spoil too much
it's fire related and then you'll kind
of see why and there's other elements of
like air and water and stuff that you'll
see um i just really enjoyed it for a
forty dollar game it's not i mean scala
said it pretty well
it's gonna be for a very specific
audience i think um i think he phrased
that very well but for those when if it
clicks for you
you're gonna want to master it it just
will depend on if you get that click
moment if you don't you may be like yeah
this sucks
um it will click for me i have no doubt
like yeah for sure you know what it
actually reminds me of more than secret
because i think people compare it to
sacro just because they're both like uh
you know there's like posture yeah
there's like those pieces but it
actually reminds me more of uh that game
fury did you ever play that game no it's
kind of on like a very long backlog that
i've got but i know what you're talking
about that was like my game of the year
that year it came out 2019 or whatever
uh
that game is fantastic dude it's a it's
like a boss rush game where you play
like a guy with a samurai sword and it's
like very much like punishing and you
gotta get through the only difference is
that sifu is a
roguelike yep rogue-like right not a
rogue light it's a rogue light there is
there is a series you do upgrade there's
upgrade progressions it's kind of
interesting kind of the way those work
um yeah but yeah there's a lightness
it's light not like
yeah so so uh the only difference is
that seafood's a roguelite and uh fury
is a boss rush but they they both have
that like same kind of cartoony
aesthetic the like lower budget type of
game made by a smaller team
uh and a very challenging kind of like
learn or die type of mentality so uh
everyone should play fury if you haven't
played it yet it's fury with an i highly
recommend that game uh and also sifu
and they have the same amount of letters
too they both have like weird names and
fury i just i can't get the comparison
out of my head the more i think about it
yeah see what uh rook and chatty saying
fury did not click with him but sifu did
so it's again it's one of those where
it's like if you try it
kind of a little bit back and forth but
uh the other one i started was i'm like
level 19 in lost ark
um nice
not like one of my friends is like level
40 has a boat going around the world and
everything's he's he's like
mainlining this thing but destiny has
dropped way too much information to be
able to try and keep up with all of it
this week and see if you would like it's
short enough if you can just kind of
squeeze in those couple levels i can at
least you know finish sifu so i'm trying
to get that one but lost ark is cool um
i went martial artists just because it
actually looks fun kind of felt fitting
with sifu anyway
but the fact that there's so much there
there's little quality life stuff hey
you start a quest here and then you
progress through the zone and then the
next quest is here and it takes you to
the next zone it's not like there's not
a lot of backtracking i've noticed which
is actually a nice quality piece i did
one of the founders packs but i haven't
like felt much of the benefit from that
one i just was like i'll do the 50 bucks
why not
and
it's just one of those where i haven't
played diablo in a while
like i played two i played three i've
played diablo like for sure for years i
played some old ones there's a game like
called knox i don't know if anybody
remembers that when it was on pc
um
i feel like if that's what it's called
but i'd have to look it up anyway it's
like diablo is still a game it's you
know there's some lucha pickup and stuff
like that
uh i could be thinking of a different
game
nope action rpg
yeah it's from 2000 so that's an old one
yeah that was old but it's also like you
might have been playing diablo 1 on a 75
hertz like megahertz computer in my
dad's office so i've been playing diablo
for forever so that type of game of
course i have to try um but it just
looks like the world is absolutely
massive so if you're looking for instead
of like diablo act 1 act 2 x3 x4 and
you're done this looks like act 1 act 75
like you've got so much content because
it is an mmo on top of an action game
yeah um there's just a lot to do so
that's just one i'll probably play in
the background a little bit here and
there but it's actually like it feels
polished like it i mean it's been out
for a couple years so i'm not surprised
outside of just probably localization
but overall it's been
very good and
it's been in preview for a couple years
in green light stage uh it's been like
like i think it's been like i don't know
if it's out or what it's been in korea
for like 20 since 2019 so it's been in
like another country for a couple of
years and this is just the first chance
for
north america to play it i think more
than anything got it i got it okay makes
sense uh but yeah this has also been the
week where bungie's like
[Laughter]
so much information i'm talking about
the new expansion i wonder why
yeah marketing marketing marketing
marketing marketing marketing and it all
started on
tuesday
with the vidoc in the morning because
they told us when it was going to drop
um i've broken down all of these on my
channel pretty deeply and talked to chat
so i want to get your takes on them
first
um for the vidoc itself we kind of have
like a couple main topics so you can
kind of pick where you want to go first
you can go campaign
the next season
the throne world or crafting void 3.0
i'm just gonna like save for later
what do you want to touch on first
i mean i don't think they told us much
about the campaign we didn't already
know except for the heroic version of it
right we got that in the twab yeah yeah
i don't know uh i don't know if we
learned anything really new from the
campaign that we didn't already know
about correctment if i'm wrong
uh i mean not a ton i would say more of
the fact that we had
just like the cinematic shot i kind of
wanted to get your take on a couple of
those
mainly the one with everybody in
zavala's office
next to everyone
yeah they gotta they gotta have some
sort of like let's get together and
battle plan this thing out actually you
know what we did learn one thing which
is that uh keital's involvement in the
beginning yeah so she's involved in
season of the risen she's in part of 16
season 16 but it seems to tie directly
into witch queen because it's like we
have lucent brood we need help so it
does seem these two tie so just very
closely
isn't dead at the end of uh the campaign
i mean we don't know if she dies and
rises like a guardian or what yet so i
mean it does look like in the viaduct
you've got a glimpse of whatever's going
to happen
oh by the way should we cover this first
the story beat didn't drop yet
season of the lost is not done
i'm starting to think it's not going to
happen i think they're just going to
start next season on on the 22nd and
that will be and that's going to be the
last season that's going to have the
chrysalis opening there's not there's
just there's nothing yeah we're all
waiting there's going to be nothing i
really do
so you think that versus say something
like next week is iron banner
now do you think they would time it with
a people are going to log in fire and
banner maybe they'll log in and see this
do you think they would try a live event
i would like them to but i don't think
they're going to
usually think just nothing you think
it's just witch queen go yup
i do i would like them to tell us i
would like them to tell us that be like
hey just don't expect any more story
stuff it's all happening when you log in
on which queen so everybody gets it
together just tell me that
yeah they might tell you that
that that's not spoiling anything that
just tells me stop waiting for it to
happen
uh the other option i was like the other
option would be we have 14 hours of
server downtime so if they tried like a
live event to shut down the servers it
would be at like
7 p.m pacific time
there's no way or 6 p.m pacific time
like that's because they would tell us
because they told us last time like
weeks in advance yeah i thought somebody
had to be logged on i feel like they
would tell us already so again i
honestly feel like they're they're not
going to uh do anything it's just going
to be
servers go down you log in we get a
cinematic of whatever happens with the
chrysalis and mara and everything else
and then we go
i think so i mean it would give
it would give the new person logging in
of all those million people who down or
pre-ordered this thing i guess
a tiny glimpse of what just happened but
it does
it's just so weird
that there's gonna be weird that there's
just nothing season of the loss though
it wouldn't be that weird for the witch
queen you know what i mean right yeah
which queen it would actually be a
really cool kickoff and actually kind of
like the idea of that but that just
means
you know don't leave me hanging at the
end of the story until the next season
that's that's just got to be
that's i feel like if this was their
plan all along they should have told us
when
uh we finished the quest that that was
all we were going to get until right i
feel like they should have just got
ahead of that way early because the fact
that people have been waiting like paul
tassie puts out an article like every
two days about when this
story beat's gonna drop and i honestly
think he's just gonna like next tuesday
he's gonna be like okay i give up like
this i think he finally been happening
right yeah i was like he started to give
up but it's like but yeah that's the
thing it's
you do all this like we've been doing
these seasons we have eight seasons in a
row now shout out to necromancer zale by
the way with kaido's involvement i hope
we get missions fighting with cabal
allies like we did the fallen before
that would actually be cool when we get
to season of the risen i would like to
see
it looks like we will because i i think
i saw in the vidoc there was uh
some of those scions were suppressing a
uh hive hive broods light yeah it looks
like maybe they're gonna they're gonna
have like mechanical
kind of impact on um
on
i think maybe story missions yeah i
couldn't tell if that was like a
cinematic like hey we have these scions
holding this thing down so we can like
study it
or if it's actually in a mission where
you got a couple and be like okay this
is happening
i saw that exact thing too where it's
like the power of the scions you
actually get to see them
basically
keeping one of the uh lucent brood
imprisoned
but yeah kaidal seems to have a
light suppression technology kind of
like the scions used for the ghost
before
and now she's kind of harnessing that
and it looks like we have some electric
spear like arc spear which is the
artifact it sounds like because people
have kind of compared the arc spear with
like the little handle to what you can
see in the little icon
for the artifact on one of the pictures
from last week's swab
um
so generally it's like i think this is
going to be the artifact but also looks
like probably for the first time the
artifact is going to have some
functionality because there's that like
five seconds where somebody's running
around in kind of like a taken shadowy
form running around throwing this like
spear thing that's up here and it's
third person so it definitely feels like
game mechanic can even i think kevin
giannis
um
he even mentioned it's like oh that
could be a mechanic huh something to
think about dropping the very obvious
obvious hint
so that is um
i'm very curious what they do with that
one but yeah it's like it's just cool to
see kyle coming back we've got zavala
crowe saladin talking to kaidel
for that shot but the cinematic shot
that kind of got me was saint 14
uh saladin
and a braves back which is actually cool
to see her back uh you've got icora
you've got zavala you've got our
guardian
i think that's just about ever the only
one who's not in that is marasav so i'll
be kind of curious where
where she ends up but it's like and then
there's the one where i core is carrying
something
out of the office and everybody's kind
of speculating what that little
image is but we can't entirely tell do
you have any i do know what part i'm
talking about with her like walking out
for that like two frames where there's
half of it looks like a little like worm
tail over here but again the other side
looks very odd it looks like a fish but
it's not
no i don't i don't i don't remember that
uh that scene i actually watched the
vidoc and a whole bunch of other stuff
this morning in preparation for the show
just to like refresh myself because
there was so much that came out i was
kind of like i don't know if i even
remember at all so
yeah there's been a lot and i've even
like broken it all down in videos and i
can't even remember everything hence
i've got a lot of notes and stuff going
around um
so from what we see we did get to see a
little bit of the throne world map
so we got to see
it seems like the first mission is going
to be like mars is like a touch point to
go to her throne world as well because
you've got her ship sitting there a
couple guardians on there i cora is
going to be standing outside and then
datto and caccus i don't know who else
got to those are the two that i know of
they got to get like exclusive like
early access kind of got to see that
that way um
and datto basically said like where
weapon crafting takes place in the
enclave which we'll get to
it's mars but it's not mars is the way
data phrases like and i'm not saying
anything else so i don't entirely know
how to take
it literally says mars on like the
screen but it's not mars
so i think it's probably a uh a hub like
um
like the uh what's the name of the war
room it's connected to the tower the
helm
the helm i think it'll be like a new
space like that and maybe there will be
like
missions related to it that are inside
of the same kind of setting you know
what i mean like story missions because
we know the first mission starts on mars
right the first major kicks off the
campaign seems like that's i think it
might be stuff like that but i think
it'll probably just be like a small
social hub where we craft weapons and
stuff we'll see
yeah i was like mostly on that one it's
just like
it seems like they're trying to say
they're not i think the implication is
it's not good they're not going to bring
back a planet size of mars like the
throne world is the destination we're
getting mars is just going to be kind of
a a portal a mini destination a little
social space i almost picture that as um
what is that like eris is it the
sanctuary on the moon like her landing
zone and you can go off that almost
probably makes more sense for me in my
head now actually that i think about it
that way but yeah we got the enclave
weapon crafting we got to know a lot
more information about weapon crafting
how
were you at on weapon crafting with
everything we got so far
yeah um i'm pretty
i'm pretty bullish on it i think uh it
looks it looks pretty good so far uh
everything
so there's there's most of the things i
like are the philosophical parts of it
right like i like that i can craft
whatever weapon i want i like that there
are
a way for me to get god rolls um i like
the idea of crafting a weapon and
building like a relationship with it as
you as you grow it up um the things that
scare me
number one
you know what i'm gonna say i know just
yeah keep to keep it the rant short but
i know what we're gonna talk about
materials man the damn materials they're
introducing all these currencies and
like i i thought they were finally
pulling back some of the currencies they
got rid of the etheric spirals they're
uh you know they're getting rid of the
gunsmith materials and a few other uh
items that aren't really useful
and then and then i see a screenshot in
the vidoc that shows
five or six new materials like new
there's four brand new ones at least so
you've got like at least four new
materials and then two alloys and two
elements that i know of that's all it's
probably gonna be a new planetary
material you gotta imagine on the throne
world i would imagine the throne world
probably has a planetary material that's
true i will say one good thing and this
is something i'd actually like them to
do more is the fact that they said
um any weapon crafting materials won't
be in your consumable like your
inventory they're just going to be
tracked
i guess just behind the scenes for your
crafting space so that's
that's something i just love to see them
do if there's a cap then we need to be
able to see that we have the cap like
somewhere on a screen or check
currencies but
no the fact that they're not at least
taking up a consumable space you could
do that with a couple other things i
think at this point just move them out
of the consumables we don't really need
those the inventory that type of stuff i
just i just hope there's a way to know
how many you have without going to the
crafting team
yeah i'm with you there that's what i
was like whether there's an on-screen
representation little ui change
yeah it did look like the caps were at
least high because you saw lots of
materials that they had but the only one
that looked like it was
the glimmer cost was really high for
whatever they were doing in that weapon
i think it was like 50k or something
like that it was pretty high it's like i
have so many screenshots now i want to
look
yeah it makes me wonder if it's gonna be
like a super high uh
glimmer cost and i'm and we're gonna be
hurting for glimmer all the time which
is not something i want
uh yeah i just i have things uh
the materials and currencies part of
destiny has always been so annoying to
me
and uh i am i'm very hesitant the fact
that they're introducing two new alloys
i know i was talking to you and cog
about this but like there's an ascendant
alloy we already have way too many
ascendant materials you know i mean like
that's just like a term that they use a
lot yeah and then and then there's the
uh what's the other alloy that they
added so we got resonant alloy which is
probably going to be from those like red
outline weapons that's probably going to
be a very common thing i think or at
least relatively decent you've got
neutral element there's like 2300 of
that in their character or like there's
a lot of that for the cost and seven
thousand that they have so they seem
okay there
the ruinous element they also have a lot
doesn't have a high cost it's the
ascendant alloy
but this is also shown when they're
crafting ossio striga and i think we're
only going to have four exotics we craft
we've got
um
osteosterego we know that one
because we're gonna have the
customizable rules there tweaks not
customizable and then you've got the
three glaives so i only imagine you
probably are going to need like a
cinnamon alloy to make like four and
then maybe if you unlock all the
different things for like osteo string
and you're like okay let me one more
time craft my first perfect one so i
don't imagine the exotic
crafting unless you're just like oh i
got one more perk craft one more perk
craft yeah then you'll probably blow
through your currency probably in a not
the best way but if you're sure that
that's just for exotics though what if
it's like for armor where it's the final
it's the final step in fully upgrading a
craft craftable weapon
just the way the currency is and the
fact that it's shown on the exotic
screen and never mentioned on any of the
others i don't think that's going to be
in the other places because the
legendaries
when they show like the little blips
that i've seen
doesn't seem to mention anything like
that one exotic element so i think that
truly is tied to the exotics i would put
my money on that one so really you've
got i hope you're right yeah so it's
like if that's what i'm worried it's
gonna be like another ascendant uh
yeah yeah i was like i think the rarity
would probably be the same so you're not
doing it all the time
for like crafting exotics but i think
that will be exotical they said the
exotic alloy will come from challenging
activities so i think that probably
would be
exotic crafting type stuff so it's going
to take you a little bit to make your
exotic uh glaive
okay and then uh
the thing i the thing that bothers me is
all the new materials that they just
sort of like offhandedly showed on
screen
makes me think that they're going the
way of
the dawning i think that like crafting
is going to be a little bit like making
cookies where there's like 20 different
you know all the different ingredients
that you collect kind of passively as
you play the game and then they all have
ridiculous names and then different
combinations to make different cookies i
don't think it's gonna be that bad i
really don't i'm just i'm wondering are
there gonna be like are there gonna be
like different materials for every
element so like the neutral one is for
kinetic and then there's like a void one
if you're making a void weapon and stuff
like are there gonna be so many
materials that
i feel like i'm always playing the
donning
you know what i mean like
i would
so if they go the alloy seems separate
the neutral and the ruminous that the
element i can't quite tell
because we've only seen it in that one
piece yeah i don't feel it's going to be
i don't think it's cookie level i don't
think you're going to have
five and 20 different things going
together
if they really go down the path of like
arc solar and void i would actually
still be surprised on that as well
because i think the bigger grind for
crafting is gonna be crafting your main
weapon once
taking that weapon all the way through
one to twenty that's the grind that i
wonder about is how long it takes a
level a weapon to go from one to twenty
and then
because they said it's not gonna be bad
but you're gonna have to spend some time
with it so it's like it's all relative
but i mean what you're unlocking is like
you're unlocking perks first but then
you're unlocking enhanced perks so any
part that you can think of right now
subsistence there's also an enhanced
subsistence so if you get 12 bullets in
the chamber maybe you're gonna get 15 or
something so those are like later parts
of the grind
um i think that's going to be the time
consuming part and they said there's
going to be like activities and the
world sources
i'm guessing
they're going to probably make crafting
for when you start
if you know life it you'll probably be
able to do decent in crafting it's going
to take you a little while to get into
but this is something they want to last
for a little while
but i also feel like later on in the
season we're going to have enough of
everything we need to do it's not really
going to matter that much that's my
hunch it's going to start a little slow
and then we're going to start
accumulating so much then it's mostly
just going to be the time with the
weapons which is the longer grind that's
what i feel is going to be the big one
that was my first reaction before they
showed the materials in the vidocq was
oh you know crafting actually doesn't
seem bad but the part that bothers me or
that i think has potential to be
bothersome
is uh the time commitment to invest in
each weapon because they tried that in
d1 and it was not good like nobody
wanted to spend time using a mediocre
weapon just so that they could upgrade
it to its finer uh final form and uh
the uh
the the solution that the community
ended up coming up with was just burning
through all of their moats of light to
skip that process and i feel like it's
inevitable that if they introduce weapon
crafting they're going to have to create
some sort of system to speed up the
weapon crafting experience point
gathering system
with the same system right there'll be
like some consumable where it like
doubles your weapon crafting experience
or whatever the heck
yeah i mean that definitely seems like
it's got a possibility to happen i don't
know for sure
they haven't said anything about it that
may be like okay this part's slow nobody
likes it so we're going to go ahead and
give you guys this that you can now
grind for
possible i don't i don't know that that
would actually be one of those times
where like all the weapon telemetry that
we have sitting around right now before
everybody turned it all in
that would be the one thing that
thematically would make sense for that
but right
that's going away along with the sixteen
thousand weapon parts that i still have
to turn in
i think turned in
twenty eight thousand this will power
you get anything good
no do you even look at it or you just do
it and dump it
i looked at it for about half a second
each weapon it's like
yeah yeah nothing that just like jumped
out to me like it was really good i just
got rid of it yeah no
i think weapon crafting is gonna be
it may fall into
it i think it's gonna give a nice
like depth to some of the weapons
because it's going to
you're going to have a lot of sources
for weapons they said there's 42 new
weapons i think there's plus probably
about six or eight exotics that they
haven't really mentioned so we've got a
lot of new weapons coming some are going
to be the random drops that you get
resonance alloy out of some you're going
to craft some are going to come from
gambit and strikes and crucible
and we actually got to see
like traits now we're seeing more
information about if you get a gambit
auto rifle it can have the trait for
this and this and you're still going to
get a lot of random rolls so you're
still probably going to get quite a few
weapons that are just like some are good
some are bad you're going to get some
good ones that you can use for a while
i think the other side of it is
rng is going to be a piece of destiny
but i think at this point it also feels
like the crafting is going to be
a longer but a direct path so you don't
have to turn in 16 000 weapon parts and
get nothing
does that make sense yeah
and that makes sense i was like i'm with
you i'm i'm definitely leaning bullish
on this as well as it gives somebody who
who does jump in who plays strikes and
does kind of more casual stuff they get
a weapon they get it and they're like
okay i really like how this one feels
let me work on unlocking everything on
it and that's just something they can
work towards
as opposed to the person who plays like
20 000 different things gets a bunch of
drops and they probably have some rng
that eventually ends up being good
right so hopefully it's like a balance
in between sound like you're not going
to be able to craft the best weapons in
the game using the crafting system right
like
there'll be god rules for that weapon
but not like the
equivalent of the um
adept you know weapons you get from
grand master or from uh
yeah i was like stuff like that yeah i
was like unless you can take it to level
20 and that opens up like another socket
because then everybody would go down to
crafting so yeah you'll still have stuff
from
dungeons that would be adapt
grandmasters that make sense to keep it
so it's like i mean it's kind of the way
they feel they said about pursuit
weapons i feel
the pursuit weapons are it's 70 of a god
roll it's a good role i think this is
going to be like
90
when you put the time 90 95
and now with like the masterworks and
stuff like that being such minimal stat
boosts
the average player can get pretty much
what they're going for if the perk
exists on that weapon without hopefully
just like
you know rolling the dice on every
single thing that they do they have a
path to go down if they want to
right
so yeah weapon crafting uh little things
that i did gather from different videos
you can't change the archetype so you
can't change it from high impact to
rapid fire if you're gonna craft a
weapon it just seems like it's gonna be
that type of weapon i don't know if you
can change it arc solar void i feel like
the weapons right now seem to be pretty
static but it's more about the perks
that you can pick
um but the enhanced perks do seem really
cool so
the fact that you can get autoloading
holster from maybe you gotta have it
holstered for like three or four seconds
now it's down to two or three whatever
the deduction is is it's probably gonna
be small but if you like the weapon
anyway all the perks you have on it just
got better
the thing that we don't know and i'm
still wondering i was kind of gonna get
your take on this one
we know
you know we're gonna have to grind the
resonance alloy it looks like for
crafting stuff and we see that kind of
floating around in some of the pictures
i still don't know what the grind is
gonna be like to unlock rampage as a
perk
unlock subsistence as a perk i know if
you get an auto rifle with subsistence
that has the resonance thing on it you
need to do something is that going to be
a pain of the butt or is it like we'll
unlock the perks first
that's a question i'm wondering do you
think the perks are going to take longer
to unlock or the 1 to 20 on the level is
going to be longer what do you think the
hardest part's going to be
um yeah i i think it's the the perks are
a one-time unlock right once you get the
resonance perk on a weapon that has that
you just dismantle that weapon and then
you can craft that perk forever that's
what it sounds like right
i don't know if it's a dismantle it
seems like there's this little like mod
like thing that you can choose to equip
and then it's got an activity progress
you do that
i just don't know it's like do you
dismantle the weapon to strip it out and
then you gotta go get another one they
haven't been exactly clear on that one
and i wish they would say a little bit
more
yeah i'm not sure but i i have a i think
the explanation they gave
and i don't remember it because it's
been a while since i looked at it but uh
the explanation they gave about how you
unlock perks seemed to me like it was
going to be pretty easy like you get
weapons thrown at you so often like it's
only a matter of time before you get one
with the right resonance and then you're
like all right what i have to do to
unlock this perk and you kind of just uh
grab it so yeah
well if the perks aren't too bad then
it's just spending time with a weapon
and you can
you know get a feel for the ones you
want to use and don't want to use or
spend time with ones i think that's i
think that'll be reasonable but i do say
it gives you another thing to go for
and hopefully it's done in a reasonable
way because as you said there can be
currencies there can be things you buy
later to speed up there's a lot of ways
it can go poorly and we're speculating
about a lot of them but i will say at
least from what we know right now i'm
very excited for it as long as and it
seems like they haven't you're gonna
lose so much time to this dude like you
more than anyone i know is gonna lose a
ton of time but hey actually you know
what in a good interview more than
anyone i know and teddy will but for us
vault orders this actually has potential
but if i get my one gun i don't need
another copy i need one of those and
then i can just work on that one so that
is actually a good thing
so if i have one of each of the weapons
that we get
that's actually pretty exciting you can
always build it later
if you dismantle it yeah i mean you
could build it you just mail it or if
you just you know unlock the perks later
go back okay now i i know i got this one
i need to get this thing up to whatever
level to unlock the enhanced version
so far pretty good
um but yeah answer somebody in the in
the in the chat asks uh travis one you
unlock think it's unlimited once you
unlock think it's unlimited you can
apply the perk any weapon you want yeah
i do think so
they haven't said that it's like gonna
be a consumable and i think
the way they've been with like mods
being cheap and perks i think as well i
think
yeah is what you're saying it's like hey
if you've got rampage unlocked cool you
got it now it's more about spending your
time with the weapon choosing it there
and having that ability i think the idea
of like if you go through the process of
unlocking because yeah if every time you
wanted subsistence oh i gotta go find
another residence one oh i gotta pull it
that would suck that would be yeah that
would be a problem so at all i think
they're gonna make it a little bit of a
mini quest or bounty to actually get
each of those perks unlocked but once
you do it you'll just be able to select
it from the weapon crafting table
anytime you're crafting a weapon that's
just my impression on the way that
they're describing it i also feel like
they would mention if it was a
consumable uh also if you were upgrading
a weapon
you probably would see
blank out of total blank perks being
used which we haven't seen in any
screenshots also true so that kind of
also tells us that it's not a consumer
yeah and it's just yeah it
again i'm yeah i'm with you i think it's
got to be an infinite unlock for the
table because the table the time with
the weapon that's where the time is they
can't double time us i feel not saying
they wouldn't well they can they can
they have never forget transmog
yeah
that was quadruple timing but either way
uh let's see so yeah campaign we know
first two missions are gonna be free for
everybody so everybody's gonna have
access to weapon crafting which is good
also that teaser be like hey you like
these first two missions how about you
come play some more and buy this
expansion
uh but i will say one thing for
the missions themselves we did figure
out is
um and this will kind of touch on the 12
i'm trying to go in some semblance of an
order but it's kind of being shot as i
talk
uh we have normal difficulty and we have
legend difficulty in the campaign
right
uh both
the missions are structured to have
a feel almost like dungeons where you're
gonna have probably some traversal and
then like an encounter with a chest
and then you move on
so it sounds like you're gonna have
encounters chests moving on maybe a
boston counter at the end of a mission
like the missions are going to be in
stages not just run over here
throw your ghost on a little thing
defend a point kill kill a worm god and
you're done
it does sound like there's going to be a
lot more to these missions from what i
can tell um you're going to have more
modifiers like rotating enemies things
of that nature but the legend difficulty
i kind of want to say this early on in
case people you know don't make it to
the end of the episode or whatever
the rewards
for legend
i saw holy crap dude that's probably one
of the most exciting things for me is
the rewards for legend because
you want me to just break that one right
now we may as well just do it yeah yeah
i was i was gonna say one other thing
that you didn't mention in you're um
talking about the story missions is they
also mentioned
uh
dungeon like mechanics yes which we have
not seen before which is really cool
yeah that was kind of said in the vidoc
they said picture things from the
your dungeons your exotic missions all
of those as you said the mechanics the
puzzles it's not just run here shoot
thing it's go here figure out what to do
and that is actually pretty exciting
because
it does feel like they're going to
that's like that's what they've needed
for a long time absolutely
um so yeah you'll be figuring out these
puzzles you might be doing it on hard
mode um but the rewards for legendary
difficulty
are well worth it and i said this in the
video i'm gonna have to update my
my video i put out on tuesday
for the leveling guide now just got a
giant i need to like
edit something in the middle and you
can't edit on youtube but the big deal
is
you get an emblem you get a triumph cool
you get a set of gear when you complete
all the missions on legends this is the
key you got to do all the missions on
legend we don't know how many but you
get a set of gear
20 points above the soft cap
so we know everybody starts at 13.50
every piece of gear when you log in
13.50
previously the soft cap is go do
anything in the game camp every single
drop blue purple doesn't matter is gonna
be two to three levels above 1500 then
you typically would go to the directory
look for legends or look for powerful
gear and pinnacle gear for your engrams
now
you go from 1500 to 1520 if you finish
those legendary missions
that is a huge jump like they've never
done anything like this before my only
question i had about that is
how difficult are the legendary missions
because they would have to be
somewhere around 1500 or lower
to make that uh set of armor worth it so
they explain here i'll explain it
because they actually kind of say it
basically it's got contests is the best
way to think about this
uh to set difficulty expectations the
legend campaign is designed to be harder
than a legend nightfall legend night
falls right now about 1320 i think
they're not too bad
uh though it is easier than a solo
dungeon or running a grandmaster
nightfall
enemies are more difficult and more
aggressive they also have higher damage
resistance or more challenge uh more of
a challenge to stagger
and
uh and shields are stronger against
unmatched damage types
so i don't know if match game is on or
if match game is late
it's definitely going to take more to
break it arbalist is probably going to
be your friend telling you know our
ballistas like those uh lucent brood uh
with the with match a game on is going
to be brutal yeah i'm telling you like
arbalist i don't know if i'm going to
take that thing off that thing's
just the fact that it can hit any shield
and then break it switch over to
hopefully a heavy and nail it that's
that's gonna be big uh the challenge of
legend also comes from switching up
enemy interactions and infiltration like
swapping out an elite for a boss or
having an influx of more red bar foes
they're actually going to have more
enemy density in certain places or more
boss and level enemies in places where
they were previously just orange bars or
elites
can i over level this content each
mission caps her power similar to raid
contest mode so that all guardians have
an even playing field to avoid feeling
like every step is a grind the mission
launch screen will have a skull
displaying
each mission's max effect of power if
you're under level be prepared for a
tough fight
so i was kind of having a debate with
chat and i was or with chat and people
in my discord and everything else do you
feel it's going to be beneficial to
beeline the main campaign and then go
back on legendary because then you'd at
least be a contest level at that point
or do you think you'll probably be able
to level with it
because there's no point in over
leveling
and you might pick some stuff up along
the way
yeah i think
i think we'll know closer once we know
how much you level
naturally during the campaign and stuff
because if the campaign is short you're
probably going to need to do the
legendary version to make it
to kind of close the gap depending and
not use your powerful drops because
if you have a guaranteed 15 20 uh
by doing legendary before you've used
any of your other drops i think that's
important but if you're already like
1500 just from being the main campaign
b-lining it you probably won't need to
go back and do legendary ever because
you can you'll just get to 15-20 just by
like doing strikes and stuff yeah i also
find i have a lot of confidence that the
community will find like a more
efficient way to level than
anything that we're thinking of right
now you know people will be like running
lake of shadows and somehow that'll get
them to like 15 40 in like an hour or
something like that it's like i could
imagine that like there's probably going
to be some elite people go in and
literally just go through probably as a
fire team they will the thing about this
it does scale per people which is
one player two player three player it's
not 3x health but they said it does
scale so it's more manageable for a solo
three people have a little bit more to
go against um but i mean if you're
getting double reward chests with one to
three extra chests per mission each
chest would give you a perk pool xp
upgrade modules glimmer
uh legend players will be able to earn
throne world armor and unlocks at a
faster rate basically a higher risk high
reward that's the obvious part but
i
i don't know i have this temptation to
really want to go legend first
just
just because like possible isn't it 1500
difficulty no it's like when you look at
the directory it's 1360 1360. you can
start legend difficulty from the get-go
oh yeah we should do that you mean cog
ultimate fire team
[Laughter]
just have to try and pull car away on a
tuesday good luck with that
yeah he's gotta be taking that day off
right i hope so i i don't know actually
i actually haven't asked him if he's got
that time off or how much he's gonna get
to play in the beginning i haven't asked
him
but yeah the big thing is
getting from 1500 to 15 20 just by doing
those missions you save all of your
weekly challenges powerful pinnacles and
all that which means honestly there are
going to be people who are 1550 going
into the raid so i mean that's not
that's not going to be a challenge i
don't think absolutely yeah
oh yeah new rad saying it's like i tend
to go into things fairly blind and
that's kind of one of those where
i'm i'm wondering if i want to try and
do it solo first or if i want to take a
fire team with me
first because that i can't decide on i
always try to do the campaigns by myself
i do too because
inevitably somebody joins my party or
hits me up with the fire team invite
it's like impossible this is why i was
uh happy that halo infinite didn't have
co-op when it launched because it meant
i had to play the halo infinite campaign
by myself because you play a co-op and
you don't understand the story because
your friends are making fart jokes and
stuff on party chat and it's just like
you can't pay attention to the story as
much so i kind of like having that uh
pure solo play
experience first and then going back and
doing it with friends and kind of going
over the top with it so
um we'll see would you do it on legend
by yourself you ran through it
that would be the part the joy of the
challenge at least
because you're show off
you little [ __ ] i mean i don't know if
i'm gonna get my you know
head knocked around a few times i'm sure
but honestly even if it takes me longer
to do it on legend once
if i can get through it on legend or
figure and then you know it's like i can
try the first couple on legend and be
like hey chat who wants to help me with
legend
but either way it's like if i can get
through it even if it takes me like
i don't know fifty percent longer i
still 15 20 gear straight away like your
average of gear is gonna rise so fast if
you can get that gear it's gonna be
so worth it to do and that way you've
experienced probably the way they would
build the campaign for you to optimally
play it because you would probably walk
through the stories you always do in a
destiny campaign la la la nothing hurts
shoot a worm god in the face and you're
dead
or you can actually experience it with a
challenge how they probably want you to
we don't get big campaign expansions
very often everybody's like oh i want
the big campaign expansion drop
well then make it a challenge and don't
ruin it on the first five minutes
yeah so he and dad is asking uh or
talking about going into blind versus
using your walk through z my uh my
policy on
i basically don't watch any youtube to
be diagnosed with everyone but uh my
policy when it comes to videos is
uh i i do everything blind rage strikes
content all that stuff blind i really
only look at ease content when it's
about like hey here's all the stupid
grinding you have to do to get ready for
the next dlc and uh here's the most
efficient way to do it like i'll watch
that video yeah he's because he's good
at uh
he's good at like hey here's how to
grind for materials and stuff you'll
need to think about for the next one but
uh yeah i don't like to like get dungeon
spoiled for me or stuff like that and i
definitely have never watched like a uh
a um
gameplay strat video like here's how to
run a nightfall or here's how to beat a
raid i've never in my life watched a
video like that so he's an elite gamer
he doesn't need help it's fine
i just like to figure it out you know
for me that's part of the fun that's the
same way with souls type stuff i'll
always go through i don't have anybody
like i don't do any summons i don't pull
anybody with me if i beat the
i can't remember it's always the
nightmare king and dark souls 3 the
optional cloud dragon boss that guy
completely evil dude
the nameless nameless king yeah that's
the second hardest boss fight i've
probably fought outside of the end of
sakura but yeah i was like i'm still
gonna figure it out a moan i'm not gonna
look up a guide when i'm done i'll go
look up it'll be like all right what's
the speed on you watch somebody just
absolutely work the guys like that's how
you're supposed to do it not like
on pins and needles pucker factor 100
and then i barely finished it with this
much healthier 100.
so wait end of sakura are you talking
about the ninja guy you fighting like
the field mm-hmm
really you had trouble with that one oh
god yes i did really
wow he was right i kind of felt like i
was always overpowered in sakura that
was like my one of my main complaints
with that game is like i just i felt
like a beast that whole game like i
could just kill anything i mean
it was the spoiler alert if you don't
want to know it's the genetic
chinechiro it's the first guy you fight
in the top
like kind of at the fork of the story
almost i feel like it's right before
then that was the fight that really
taught me the game that forces you to
parry because you're really not going to
beat him without pairing i had kind of
gotten through
and then finally when the parry starts
clicking i'm like okay cool just the
mechanics the range of the final guy was
yeah it took me a while that was
multiple streams hours of trying that
was a hard one for me for sure did you
play the optional one where you fight
your uh your adopted father in the
hallway no
i i never went back for the other fork
in the story i didn't do that yeah so i
did that and i actually preferred that
that one's crazy the fights in that like
he's he's crazy when you fight him in
that second fight but uh yeah i got
every achievement in that game that's
true i loved that game a lot yeah that
was i tell people it's like it
it's not dark souls the fire demon is
dark souls in that game which will throw
off your practice because it's all about
dodging learning and getting out of the
way there's nothing to parry on him you
just can't get smacked in the face with
a fire paw
but yeah that when you realize it's not
the dodge outside of one or two bosses
yeah that game had so many cool moments
the monkey is still one of the greatest
things and then i went to go see about
the reaction videos of that one people
be like cool and just the freak out
moments oh yep
rook even said it right here in chat
he's like that stupid undying ape made
me quit securo
rook if you're this far into in into
sifu you gotta beat sakura man
anyway sorry off topic discussion there
but yeah i do think the legend
difficulty
should probably be a good challenge and
i think contest is actually going to
keep the legend difficulty as a nice
place to practice either being under
leveled or just being at the level that
they want you to be at so things are
always a challenge i like that that will
always be there because contest mode a
lot of people ask for in raids they
would like it to be permanent
so you could actually always go back and
hey i want to do deep stone crypt with
contest on just to get that experience
and then if you can beat it it'd also be
a way to practice for day one raids and
that stuff so the fact that the campaign
is going to hold that mode i think is
actually really cool
it should be permanent and it should
guarantee your exotic drop
yeah if you can do it on contest then
yeah absolutely you should do it
i think definitely at least on uh if you
do contest mode day one it should
guarantee your exotic drop because i
beat i beat contest mode on deep stone
[ __ ] that first day it was out and uh 50
runs later still still had to do you
know a full year of of grinding that
raid before i got ice up tomorrow so
yeah that's why i still don't have vexes
because every so often is going to be
like hey you want to get in the vex room
i'm like sure but i like i don't tend to
go seek out and do three every week it's
just
i got other stuff going on i would much
rather do other things than that you may
never get it man yeah and that's the
thing it's like i see people at 60 70
and i'm like
i'm this far in nope
it's just that that doesn't that's
something i hope they
handle better with witch queen but we
will see i'm trying to think of other
stuff from the vidoc so season 16 season
the reason we got kyle we do have a new
perk so the season 16 origin perk which
the perks like the origin traits
actually seems really cool it's called
land tank
shocking of course because it's coming
from the cabal
it is basically the opposite of rampage
the more kills you get you're going to
get increased damage resistance and
resilience so if you're sitting there
killing a lot of adds
now you're going to be harder to kill
so i can see that being really
beneficial in like smgs for proximity
swords and theories the most titan perk
i've ever heard oh absolutely go in
punch
shoot you could just melee a bunch of
stuff melee you get stronger
yeah
yeah so that one actually seems pretty
cool um i'm actually pretty excited
about traits it's going to give the
weapons just a little bit more
uniqueness where you can
you know you take the trials weapon into
a solo
lost sector because it works for a solo
build that type of stuff that i'm
excited to see oh you're doing low-level
stuff take the strike perk where every
kill gives you seven health and you just
like constantly run or if you need the
champion one stun a champion you get
like 60 recovery straight away
and then you're gonna be able to pick
between the two they really are giving
us a lot of
flexibility on our weapons between the
crafting and the traits and the
flexibility like the pursuit weapon has
crucible strikes and gambit so
theoretically if like you get a shotgun
the pursuit weapon is gonna be a shotgun
which is unfortunate but
it's not gonna be too exciting for me
that feels like more of a
crucible weapon than anything
right
so that's most of season 16 i would say
with the
the tusk armor thumbs up thumbs down
what do you think
no no that's the that's the gladiator
gladiator thumbs down i think all the
armor that they've shown so far is kind
of ugly i didn't really like the uh
witch queen astrology armor that though
oh see i like that stuff i like all the
elemental or the elements in the like
nacl just i don't know i like the look
of the dark color with the green but i
like dark green i like green so it's
like a kind of a black and green
contrast where the green like the little
emblems pop that's i don't know for me
it actually works and if my titan could
have some lean shoulders
i haven't found anything cooler than my
uh iron banner samurai armor
i mean that's not a bad one
yeah
um so tusks know we'll have to see if
cog is down for the tusks but what can
we do
he's down for everything you guys so
positive
it's fair
uh let's see throne world we know the
enclave we've got a couple other areas
that we can see the big thing about the
throne world is
kind of the
difference
of the two areas that we've got we have
the vibrancy the brightness the
basically it's her fortress area her
palace is a nice way to say it it's got
the hive architecture but it's basically
white and this is and they even talk
about it in the video of the vidoc of
her
it's a representation of her personality
it's her trying to leave the darkness
behind and kind of suppress that that's
the swamps that's the underbelly that
we've seen with like kind of the fiery
pits that's the pyramid ship kind of the
darkness in the background versus the
light side
the
you know her trying to basically pair
with the light and it says that's what
we're trying to stop which we got a
little bit today
um another thing i uh i noticed that
kind of disappointed me
is it sounds like from the interactive
trailer they showed
that they're actually not going to show
how sabbathun stole the light
because in that um in that time in that
interactive trailer they basically say
like oh yeah sabathune has stolen the
light right it takes place in like the
the future basically because they we
already apparently know that she's still
in the light by that point because the
core is narrating how she's stolen it uh
which hasn't happened in the game yet um
but in it it says that like we're not
sure how she stole the light but it
might have been related to sabbath and
song
and so if we start up yeah you'll see
and and like
the sabbath just has the power of the
light and we're not sure why i'm going
to be like
really there was no like big betrayal
moment where she like took it or
whatever but i think that also kind of
disappointed i think that might be why
that's what we're trying to do in the
campaign maybe that's the journey we're
going on because i don't think we're
gonna yep
that would be my guess is like trying to
figure out what happened i don't think
we're gonna kill sabathune and we all
pray that we won't at the end of the
campaign we hope she's a longer lasting
possible ally i'm starting to feel like
that's correct i think we've all always
wanted to but i was up the opinion that
even though that's what we wanted they
were going to kill her anyway but i'm
starting to believe that now she might
not die just based on all the kind of
evidence around it that we're seeing
specifically with the season of the
risen and stuff like that i i think
she's probably still going to be alive
see the other thing about sabathan's
song farcado even said it in chat too
um i imagine the stole the light is the
survive the truth moment that could be
part of it too but the other thing i
thought was cool is
this actually because you mentioned
sabithun's song and it was the void
light
and i honestly wonder if this is their
story lore implementation
for the rework of void 3.0 which
actually would like i would appreciate
the effort that goes into hey we
reworked your subclasses hey due to the
hive getting this light we've reworked
these things and now we've got some
changes going on and nikora is the main
one who's part of that i was like if
they go into that much depth just to
rechange the subclass like the writers
do that i was like i have to give them
props just for going the extra mile to
give a reason as opposed to hey we
reworked your subclasses you can mess
around with them now
well here's the why and i was like i
appreciate that if that's there if not
then you know it's still cool they're
there but it was like if they actually
went the extra mile and gave us a lie
i think that's pretty cool they're
pretty good at giving us explanations in
the lore they gave us a
a reason why stasis was nerfed in the
lore recently so why i don't know if i
never remember that
oh it was like uh the the darkness
basically turned its own power down
because
uh by
for the same reason viruses become
weaker so that they don't kill its host
they didn't they didn't want to
discourage guardians from stopping using
the darkness by like by being too scary
so it like adapted to make itself weaker
so that it could live on so it's a
little more even-keeled not too much
yeah yeah exactly they gave like a a
reason like the darkness is smart enough
to realize that it it's it's like acting
on its own survival and i was like damn
they like created a lower reason for why
stasis got nerfed this is crazy yeah
other games they just like nerfed this
thing here okay we have to know this
thing writers why is this happening we
need we need some justification for a
weapon
lore moment go
yeah so to that point i i do think
you're probably right that uh that that
it's a red herring the sabbath in song
explanation i think they just put that
in the trailer to mislead us and
but it's still gonna be weird right it's
gonna be weird when when the the game
comes out and all of a sudden she has
the light and it doesn't give you an
explanation our first thought is going
to be like what like what like
nothing right and then uh
there probably will be a moment in the
campaign where she reveals that like you
know the light was given to her
willingly or some other explanation and
then we're like oh damn like this is way
worse than we thought so
yeah i think it's going to be a question
of like what is the guardian who is the
light the other moment actually that was
a cool thing and random spoiler if you
didn't want to see it but we've all seen
it at this point
um they mentioned the first moment you
grab a hive ghost
and you crush it
and they're like and then it's that like
you're kind of looking at your hand kind
of expand after you crushed it basically
questioning what you just did because we
are guardians because of our ghosts so
the importance of the ghost is almost
more than our flesh like the ghost is we
don't do anything without the ghost the
fact that we're sitting there crushing
somebody else's ghost who's giving them
light
are we good are we bad what are we doing
i thought that was like i hadn't thought
about that i was just like damn even in
playing the story you might not catch it
that much but now that they said it
actually makes me think about it a lot
well it's funny i'm glad they put that
in the game because i was i i was like
you like when i said oh you got to kill
ghosts the first thing i thought was
well that sounds like an annoying
mechanic that they're going to be
respawning that was where my brain went
right because i review video games but
when i told my girlfriend about it she
was like oh no i don't want to have to
kill a ghost like that sounds terrible
that was her first reaction so
when she saw that i showed her the vidoc
today and she saw that she killed the
ghost she was like that's what i was
talking about i don't want to have to
kill them that's too sad like that was
her first reaction so
that's that's really funny um
i i uh i'm wondering if if hive are
guardians now lucent brood i think we
can say our guardians yeah they say high
of guardians i mean there's a point
where apparently even they cast their
super it shows up in the little kill
feed in the corner i think i heard i'm
going oh damn yeah
so does that mean that this is a civil
war between the guardians
i don't know if the lucent brood or
anywhere else that's the question i have
for like season 16 because some people
weren't i thought if season 16 partially
takes place on the moon i don't know if
some people were saying there was a
um
basically here's something well not
leaving a leak but like the little
picture we got of some of like the ships
flying in and this weird thing it looks
like it was
almost
almost like moon ark like it was kind of
the cliff side of a moon but it's like
very hard to tell where that's at
because typically like the seasons don't
typically take place in the same
destination so maybe it's like they're
trying and the moon would be the other
tie-in because it also looks like you're
driving through the scarlet keep in a
little bit of the clip for season of the
risen
uh moon edc so far so yeah four cotto's
pretty on on top of it too yeah moon and
edc but yeah moon definitely seems
involved in seasonal arizona since we do
have hive the scarlet keep there
so yeah i'm wondering uh
i'm wondering if because you know humans
technically aren't the only species that
are guardians there's humans but there's
also exo and awoken so like
you know in a perfect world if if the
hyver guardians they didn't steal the
light they were just given it doesn't
this just mean that there's now a fourth
race of guardians that that should you
know are am i going to be able to make a
hive character guardian in a year from
now you know i would love to do that but
i'm going to go with no
yeah
that would make sense to me right like
it feels like that's what should happen
so that would be if we went into other
classes could you imagine making like a
fallen captain with a completely
different loadout and skill tree set
then you've got a hive guardian you can
go nice
i can after final shape i can't imagine
that see that is where i would i would
be curious to see it go there that would
be very cool but i think we've got to
get through normal guardians through
final shape i'm with you there
okay
but yeah that's that's the exciting
stuff that's like what are they going to
do at destiny in the future they have so
much potential in the world that they've
built between the writers the lore and
everything else
yeah that'd be that'd be really fun
um i'm trying to see oh there's like
these little hive moths by the way
and they will like shield hive and then
if you like somehow can kill that one
the hive's gonna go find another the
little moths gonna go find another one
you can shoot the hive out of midair but
apparently you have to pay attention to
these little moths too so pay attention
to those
i also saw finisher with the moth where
it's like where they like kind of blow
the kiss but they blow the moth and just
like it's the finishing move that's cool
um
i think that's most of is there anything
else from the vidocq i feel like we've
definitely touched on a lot of points
from the dog weapon crafting against his
world that beard the bearded guy who
does the sound effects is still my
favorite person dave samuel i think is
his name yeah he's like and then when
you the lightning guy goes
when he goes into sound effect mode yeah
he's the most enthusiastic guy has to be
in all vitox it's a must i've uh i've
hung out with that guy and he's always
like that that probably sounds like the
perfect guy to get a beer with then like
yeah he's just very he's super high
energy and super jolly i
man i miss hanging out with the bungee
team it's been too long coveted sucks
that's true
maybe gcx will get to hopefully
hopefully yeah yeah great are you gonna
get a chance to go do you think oh yeah
okay is it still happening yeah when
does it happen um i'm basically the last
thing i heard for gcx is that they are
gonna have like online testing some
middle and stuff like that so i mean
they're putting that in place it sounds
like they're going for it so
cool
pretty exciting stuff florida let's do
it man yep all right we've like cog and
i have our hotels booked already so we
got that one it's just plain tickets
[Music]
oh yeah we've had those
for
a while
wow so without me how dare you i think
we did that before you were on
pretty sure
all right i'm sleeping on your couch you
can sleep on in cogs room just get him
get two queen beds and you can take the
other one so or are you gonna spoon i
guess that and you might have to figure
that one out we're gonna spoon
big spoon or little spoon what are you
the fact that he's not here he would be
dying right now yeah i'm gonna cast that
bubble shield over our bed
oh that's amazing
um
so i think that kind of puts a a pin on
the vidoc
next major thing we got because it has
just been a week of news and news and
news and news
void 3.0
are you excited
yes
i am
even though it seems like the commander
titan is gone
uh what do you mean like the middle tree
the uh the the shield
titan that buffs it looks like that
maybe is not at least they didn't they
didn't uh showcase it in like the new i
think that yeah you're still gonna have
the option for that
yeah you think so i hope so it seems
like they're doing everything right like
they're not taking away any of the old
things but i love that bubble shield
doesn't have a delay that annoys the
crap
that was big because they mentioned the
pvp implications of pop the bubble if
like you can go instant defense that was
really nice
i've been killed by shotgun a lot while
i was trying to cast my bubble shield
and also sometimes it just doesn't work
you ever hold down both and then it just
does a regular
titan shield and you're just like god
not what i was trying to do so it's
really nice to just like choose one and
go with it
um yeah i i'm i'm very excited man about
all the changes to avoid i what's great
is that um
i think void is the one that needed the
most work on the titan side
it's always been so poorly designed for
the titans and i think it's because
the titan bubble shield was sort of an
afterthought remember they kind of added
it later it wasn't in destiny 2
1.0 they added it after after a while um
it felt like it felt like it was tacked
on so
it's needed a lot of work on the titan
side for a long time so i'm really glad
they're doing it and uh
yeah i'm excited man it's gonna be cool
yeah i mean they even mentioned the
light subclasses haven't seen a whole
lot of love void abilities haven't
really been developed since 2017
and we're in 2022 so i mean five years
it's been a little bit of a minute to
say the least um but yeah they kind of
break down the main verbs that they're
talking about i saw somebody give them a
hard time for creating um you know words
now which was funny
but they do mention specific words just
for what's happening suppress uh the
target is taken out of any activity of
any active ability and you cannot
activate an ability or uh movement modes
combatants are disoriented so that's
suppress
weaken targets take increased damage
slowed and disoriented
volatile basically if they take
additional damage they'll explode also
if they die they explode that one always
reminds me of middle tree titan i love
the chain explosions when you get that
as a middle tree titan
that's way too much fun oh the grenade
and it's just fireworks to go off so i'm
glad to see that's going to be a lot
more apparent invisibility
i don't think we're ever going to see
hunters ever ever again i'm pretty sure
hunters are just going to be invisible
all the time it's going to suck i'm
pretty sure and i'll get to why
overshield that's going to be our
defense thank god
the player gains protective barrier and
then immediately stacks on top of their
shields we know that it also reduces the
damage taken from pve combatants and
then devour the warlock world of fun
players immediately restored to full
health upon activating devour from any
source and is granted grenade energy
when the player gets any kill with
devour active they are restored to full
health granted grenade energy and the
debuff of the buff timer is extended
so titans you mentioned the insta bubble
very cool um happy to see that one
the bastion so our overshield that we
get from
basically putting down a wall or the
rally barricade also in that video the
rally barricade looks about twice as
wide didn't it
yeah that's because uh there's a um
a new perk they talked about it uh
in the it's like an aspect or something
that makes the shield really wide i
think that's a super also
i think they mentioned that that's one
of the super one of the new supers that
you can do uh in the one of the new
versions of it but yeah uh they talked
about something that was in the uh the
vidoc i believe
or maybe it was void 3.0 god they've put
out so much stuff i know i can't get
that i was like confused i've
overstepped some things talked about
otherwise that was a super like you just
get a really big uh titan walls one of
your supers yeah um but basically you've
got the main aspects are gonna be the
big things obviously the game changers
control demolition hitting a target with
avoidability or volatile detonation will
make them volatile
so
that's your middle tree titan start
chaining those explosions and they're
going to go off so that's exciting you
can just have void all the time
uh then you've got bastion uh casting
the barricade generates overshield for
yourself and your allies that's the one
they showed so you'll cast it
uh no word on cog we don't know if we're
gonna get him in here as well we're
trying we told him it's the option he
can come in whenever but at this point
uh you guys literally speak of the devil
he literally just went from off on
discord to on on discord so i'm gonna
you summoned him i may have his ears may
have been burning we will see
um controlled demolition so bastion yeah
so you get an overshield looks like it
lasts for 10 seconds he runs out
shoots somebody runs back to the
overshield and refreshes his overshield
behind the barricade again
um so you can literally have that
barricade kind of come and go and
that actually seems really really cool
and then the offensive bulwark while you
have hunt over shield and are inside the
ward of dawn grenades charge
significantly faster and you have
increased melee damage so your word of
dawn just got nicely more potent faster
grenade charge increased melee damage
and you gain an additional shield throw
with your sentinel shield super it's
kind of so it's working both ways so
that is your sentinel shield so you've
got that and the throw and more got it
okay um yeah i'm uh i'm especially
you know what's most exciting about all
this is not even the stuff that they've
added it's the fact that they can always
add more aspects and fragments and that
sort of stuff and they can they can just
add new abilities which i feel like
there wasn't as much freedom to do under
the old i mean you had three yeah you
had three forks that's all you could do
it's they were stuck it was so limiting
like
i've always dreamed of a mod that allows
me to pick up my rally barricade and
throw it different places you know so
like deploy it and then you can kind of
sort of like reabsorb it and throw it
over here and then reabsorb it and throw
it over here and just kind of keep using
it until it breaks because uh you know
sometimes you put a shield in one spot
and it's not uh
you know then the situation changes and
you want it to be somewhere else i
thought that would be that'd be cool so
i just want to see the new stuff they
come up with that we don't know about
yet
yeah and that's what i'm wondering about
so they will cover it kind of in the
twab a little bit but they mention
um
new players are going to have set
abilities kind of unlocked from the
start and it sounds like some of the
best ones like new players are going to
start with the good ones that kind of
flesh out the other stuff um if you've
been playing for a while you're gonna
have just about everything except a few
things they said that we're gonna unlock
after the raid which is weird timing but
they will be there probably because
they're game game changing kind of thing
i was kind of thinking i was like okay
so we're going to wait on the game
breakers like oppressive darkness with
every grenade which we'll get to that
was crazy can you believe that also i'm
i'm kind i'm kind of bemoaning the fact
that uh everybody gets suppression
grenades because that i really thought
that was something that made uh the
titan defender subclass unique so
but in theory like we're gonna get a
little bit of everything that we haven't
had either so there are some good ones
that's true
um
but yeah void void 3.0 are we gonna get
those fog grenades what are those things
no because that's the ability yeah
that's a male ability but we're gonna
get because right now we have the wall
we have the suppression and then
magnetic is that r3
yeah so now we get spike we get vortex
we get scatter like those are the fun
ones oh we're gonna use the the
devouring
what's that thing called or it's like a
one-hit grenade the handheld supernova
we don't get that one we don't get
handled supernovae
nope so basically they said for hand out
supernova for warlocks you're skipping a
little but basically if you use the
thing where you can supercharge your
grenades and they can do it to most of
the void ones if you supercharge the
magnetic grenade that's your handheld
supernova they mentioned so there's
man they did mention that that would
i think they mentioned like there are
some tiny nerfs to places where you
might not be able to get double
um
hold on one sec we got possible cog um
cog action in the chat
oh he joining yeah he's coming he's
coming we're getting cog in so
mid point mid join points about an hour
and 20 in we got the uh [ __ ] join
and that means i've also got to be on my
uh fast click twitch here it'd be like
cog joins and switch scenes
i can't wait i'm gonna see how uh how
quickly do it
i just gotta know if he's start
recording and joining
five
four
three come on cog hit my timing give me
two
come on two and a half
two and three quarters i'm counting up
now he's just like in the bathroom right
now like nowhere near he's starting
recording he's and joining
join
join
anytime join this is great content right
here anytime best best part of the
podcast right here just waiting for cog
anytime
loving it absolutely loving it yes okay
so right now what we're waiting on is
cog to click the button we need him to
go ahead and click the join button
and now now now
now he's definitely in the bathroom
right now
he is dropping the kids off at the pool
he will be here in a minute
he needs some fun time with the homies
everybody when he gets in here blow up
chat make him feel welcome you know he's
uh he's had a rough day if he didn't get
to join us from the start so
join the call sir
you know what we could do as well click
the video with a a chance maybe
celebratory cheer
to the
bow to the cog
no we need like we need the ninja
cognito
there he is
there's my boy and he's got a drink hey
i see i see an ibontis ice shaker it's
kind of sweet
all my levels my levels are right uh
you're a little up alternating
yeah you're good oh okay cool let's go
to our eyes are beautiful thank you
i was just talking about getting some
alone time with you in a hotel
make sure my floor is different from
your flight we were talking about sex at
gcs
a little bit a little bit of that going
on in the chat today
i needed this it's been a it's been a
rough week it's been a rough week
what's going on we got
what we got what we got so we were
talking yeah you missed us you missed us
talk about the vidoc you just talk about
legendary campaign on the story and now
we're sort of j oh yeah you also must
just talk about weapon crafting so
really this is the last topic right
yeah so we gotta we gotta get his take
though like we gotta we gotta backtrack
a little we gotta go back a little and
ask this man
there you go now i can i still can't see
the top of your head and frame but yeah
it's cut off
your head is working hey there we go oh
my god i can see the top of your head
it's been it's been months since i've
actually got the top of his head in
frame so
really yeah actually it rarely happens
um no seriously like where how much have
you caught up with this week how much
have you stayed in tune with have you
missed anything
where are you at all right so i caught
the um the legendary uh
modes that they're adding and how
basically how they're gonna do the
rewards and stuff like that i did catch
that so shout out to tassie i did catch
a little bit of that but um as far as
the void stuff this is where i need to
be i have not really caught up with that
okay but as far as yeah as far as the um
the campaign the i mean the initial
trailer i saw everything was cool from
that so i'm pretty much where we at
right now where i jumped in
like this is yeah do you have any like
what i see free stuff like from the
video like big stuff that you've seen
any major moments any cool excitement
pieces
what from what you've seen so far like
what do you i mean we've talked about it
but i still want to know like are you
like are you extra hyped like this thing
looks cool these people are here what do
you got yeah i liked it i i definitely
like the fact that um we had from a
story standpoint you know how i am with
all the characters being in there right
so you're seeing shacks shout out to
saladin i was happy to see you because
you're never around when it's on when
it's on saladin does not know it's never
around see osiris in that video i know i
know and that's what i was talking about
dj dj was on yeah it's a wrap dj was on
the stream with us i grabbed them up
and i'm like it's not mentioned
i don't see like it just do i think when
she when she breaks out she do the ooga
booga she gonna dump a body bag on the
floor and say see i delivered him to you
like i said
here he is as he dies in your arms or
something i just died in your arms at
night bro it looks spooky and the fact
that say 14 was i saw him in
that group you know with what i carried
everyone that was interesting so yeah
that was my only main concern but as far
as the uh the story stuff it looked good
man i like i liked what i saw for
dividend i definitely
no complaints from me i still feel
they're holding out though i still feel
there's still more and they're not
giving us a lot about the raid you know
the typical they got to stretch this
thing out oh yeah um weapon crafting
thumbs up thumbs down where you at
all right
it i've as i got more information
i'm warming up okay the question yeah
the question now becomes
with those because they they almost have
that red outline right yep so
yeah yeah so with that
is it going to be a situation where
there are my question you guys is there
a situation where they are set
randomization on the perks that you
acquire and then you can get the beefed
up versions afterwards like that that's
my question we don't know 100
my
we were kind of talking about this
basically the assumption we think you
get a weapon with
subsystems rampage cool uh you've got
it's got the red outline so you can get
the resonance alloy to do whatever the
little mini quest activity is our
assumption is you're going to do said
little activity unlock rampage for your
crafting table
permanently we hope if it's not that is
a bad choice so we're hoping that's a
more permanent thing because you're
gonna have to level up your weapon to 20
anyway so that's the thing
my guess would be
we don't have a way to unlock an
enhanced perk in the first place
so i'm assuming we have to unlock
rampage and then as you level up the
weapon if you have rampage then when you
get high enough on said weapon rampage
enhanced then becomes unlocked to go
ethic that's the way it logically would
make sense in my mind and if it's not
then um in my opinion they may have done
something wrong but hopefully that's how
they do it because that's the way at
least in my my head
that makes some sense
yeah that feels right to me i i think
that the um
i'm i'm coming around on it i definitely
feel that this makes a lot of other
weapons going to be obsolete with the
soft sun setting soft sun setting yeah
soft sun setting crazy what you think
chad which i think it's
yeah i also think like uh a lot of
things we're gonna do it anyway like the
weapon traits thing i guess is already
gonna make a lot of weapons obsolete i
feel like
uh there's just so much this was the
right time to do it if they're going to
overhaul the way weapons work anyway and
also they admitted that crafting isn't
going to let you create god rolls it'll
get you like 70 or 80 of the way through
but it's not going to let you create
like
equivalent to weapons you can earn adept
from grand master nightfall see i'm
sitting there thinking my head about
that because i know we literally just
got done talking about that but i wanted
to ask
adept weapons you get from a grand
master what does adapt to do it gives
you an adept slot you could put you know
big ones or whatever that one is on it
but on the crafted weapons
i haven't seen really a place that we're
gonna get enhanced perks anywhere else
so in theory the enhanced perks like
rampage autoloading holster if you have
enhanced version of those
that adept weapon isn't going to do much
for me now if you have raid specific
perks you can't get somewhere raid
specific traits that really set
something apart maybe but i think the
crafted weapons are going to be
very potent
even in comparison to like a grand
master which also makes me question how
are they really going to set those other
ones apart if it's because
a little bit of an adept mod socket
thing doesn't seem quite as strong if i
have enhanced perks and what do you care
for a little bit of range
or the actual perks that function so i'm
not sure honestly
yeah i don't know i don't know how
they're going to handle it
um yeah everybody's who's in here by the
way now that cogs here smash that like
button i think you're muted
yeah sorry i said how we feeling about
the gleeve
i'm very curious because the melee is
like a stab backstab overhead smash it
actually looks like it could feel like a
decent combo
uh for the melee the projectile is kind
of a that's the one thing we didn't talk
about travis we failed um
the projectiles like they said you kind
of need to lead the target so it's like
slightly slow tracking it sounds like so
it's not going to be
that's not hit scan that's going to be a
slower piece kind of what i picture
symmetry's all fire's probably like
um ah good yeah good enough that would
be the closest i can picture in my head
and then we've got the shield which it
sounds like you need to charge the
shield up
with the projectile shots and the clips
seemed to be about a magazine of like
six
but that's kind of what i've gathered so
far at least from that point that was
that like i feel like it's gonna require
too much thinking to use a glaive
like uh i know that's the most tightened
thing you've ever heard but like you
guys know what i'm talking about
there's some weapons where like you
spend most of your time doing math like
sometimes i feel like
vex mythology you're like all right one
kill two kill now use the charge thing
and you're like worried about efficiency
and then at some point you're like you
know what this is not the right way to
play the game is to like think so much
about like my ammo and it's especially
true of like terrible that's like a
perfect example where you're just like
you have to your whole
your all of your gameplay is around
charging up that perk and you have to
like double down on it and i just feel
like the glaive if there's like a lot of
like
interplay between the melee versus the
range versus the charging up the shield
at a certain point you're just gonna be
like you know what i'm just gonna find
something that requires a little bit
less like uh planning to use and it kind
of just lets me run wild
that's just what i got from the glaive i
was like this seems like a lot to have
to think about it feels i don't think
they would introduce uh necromancers
aisle with the second super chat thank
you sir for another five bucks how hard
is it going to be to unlock the options
in weapon crafting we're all kind of in
speculation mode
um
i'm guessing whether you have to you
have to go find a recipe or a blueprint
so that might either be a quest or
strikebot i don't know where those are
going to drop from and david oros with
the second super chat
hey yinz
long time listener big fan of the show
can't catch this live but i'm sure i'll
enjoy it once i'm out of work thank you
for all that you do we appreciate it so
much
who's wins i don't know
what he's saying cj at work you know he
got he he keeps trying man tried to boy
keep trying to get me 1k i just gave up
i'm like bro i'm good at life you know
like i've just accepted it it's like
something like that before i am with vex
that's where i'm with vex i've just
accepted like i'm this far gone i don't
need to start my journey down 60 raid
runs for this thing i'm good
like yep
gets it again could get continue yeah
yeah sorry to answer the first question
i was just going to say i think
unlocking options in crafting is going
to be very similar to unlocking
catalysts for weapons there's some
randomness in terms of getting it to
drop right you've got to get a thing to
drop that has the perk on it and then
you do like a mini quest that probably
involves just like mostly killing things
or doing specific small activities and
then you unlock it and then you have it
forever i think it'll be just like
getting um getting catalysts
it
yeah it wouldn't be destiny without some
form of rng in the process of collecting
it yeah yeah sure yeah yeah biggest
thing i would say is like any of the red
outline weapons
look at them
don't just be like oh this
don't delete that without looking at it
please because that's where you're going
to be getting those from spend a little
time use that random sidearm that
dropped get the perks off of it then you
can probably deuces and put in the trash
but for the time being
get the perks get the quest done get
what you need out of it then you can pat
then you can move on absolutely
absolutely but yeah
i have one question that i missed that i
had to ask y'all um for this for travis
um what what you think is the um
the random three little worms in the
cinema like they look like three souls
in the world did y'all see that oh the
three of the that looks like like almost
like a throwback to like fundament or
because again you've got akka that's
been killed saw that we akka was killed
by oryx rx however but that's that one
zoll we killed on a strike which is
still fun so the three left are y'all
er
and
higher or something like that there's
three other ones that's probably them if
that's some weird if we get a cinematic
where you know savathun's having a
nightmare about the worms or something
yeah then sign me up because that would
be actually pretty awesome um i think
just have to appear in her throne world
right because they're such a big part of
her history
yeah i think picture that is like some
setup because it looks like aikora's
looking out over
some like kind of like white sand desert
with a little mini crater and a couple
crystals and then it looks like the same
thing and the worms are all around
so i don't know if it's an icora
cinematic for something that she sees or
some vision of sabathin's mind
but i definitely know what you're
talking about is like why are there
three giant worms this is a big deal
come on
i was like what's going on here yeah i
had to ask that all right now what i
want to do i'm very i'm very uh
interested in what happens because also
there's sort of a betrayal going on here
like uh sabathun is sort of uh
turning her back on the deal that they
made with the worms
uh all those years ago and i i feel like
that's gotta have repercussions like if
we're trying to take out savithune are
the worms our allies now technically
like they they kind of want revenge on
this uh this lady as well
are they gonna starve because it's kind
of like don't the worms eat the hive
when they don't give them enough
violence you know what i mean so like
are they just going to starve to death
now that they don't have an army killing
for them like i'm just very
interested in how that's going to evolve
the story and that sort of thing but or
it's going to be this is
this is much crazy so deep in the lore i
would be really surprised if they
focused on any of this just because it's
so
like
it's got to be like what 98 percent of
fans have no idea what a hybrid god is
or something like that i would agree i'm
just not gonna know what the heck we're
talking about so that's that's always
been the problem with destiny's story i
just don't know how they how deep they
can go in the game i will say i was very
happy to see kaidal
i was like okay
yeah we talked about that part we talked
about okay
uh existence and the nature of that
season pretty much confirms sabaton's
not going to die in the campaign
because we're still fighting her lucent
brood and
trying to figure out how to take the
light from them so
unless savathuna's dead and her
hive are still running around as
guardians i i don't see uh
i don't i don't think he's smirking i
think that's which is no me it's chat
it's chat oh okay yeah no i agree i
think i think the theory
i think we might be safe from the uga
yeah we beat you up
it's over i think well
i think we
is something bigger and grander because
they they haven't given away too much in
the world of spoilers which i appreciate
we don't know what i cora is caring and
she kind of walks out of the room kind
of somberly we don't know what she's
looking at but the big thing is it seems
like
they're very excited about what is gonna
happen with savathun they're like i'm
really excited to see what you guys
experience here and i don't think they
would be of that level
of excitement if it's just like hey i
can't wait to kill this in mission seven
it's like i don't think that's going to
be that way and we also know that the
pyramid ship is not her
like the raid boss is not her they've
mentioned some ancient evil or whatever
that's going to be so again are are we
helping her detach from the darkness and
the worm of what i was laughing at in
chat by the way somebody was just like
fine uh final sabothune encounter would
be called d worm sabathune and i just
joked and i said ivermectin actually has
a use now
so if you've been keeping up with the
news you know what i'm talking about i
may have pissed off half of the our
audience right there but some of you
guys know what i'm talking about with
that one
anyway but i think the idea is like like
sabathune
does feel like something that's gonna
have a longer chain of events to it and
i think that's exciting and that's what
we've all wanted
yes
no ooga
finally finally
uh yeah but i mean campaign we talked
about legendary campaign do you see the
rewards for that thing
did not okay so that i want to touch on
for you because this is big so
um
legendary campaign what are the main
rewards
so you've got double chest rewards
offering one to three extra chests per
mission each chest will give you a pool
of gear upgrade modules glimmer that
type of stuff legendary players will be
able to earn throne world armor and
unlocks faster basically high risk high
reward they basically describe the
missions though as like dungeons here's
an encounter beat the encounter chest
move on like the missions have
encounters to them so there's definitely
depth to them
okay we got that structure yep
are there any unique rewards for
completing the story on legend
difficulty you got an emblem you got a
triumph okay eight upgrade modules i
know i'm not selling you yet right
nothing nothing great
bungee reward stuff no you're good
how about if you beat all the missions
on legendary you get a set of gear
that's 20 20 levels above uh soft cap
okay so you go
if you beat all the legendary missions
you all of a sudden go 15 20.
okay okay i'm listening i like that
i like that so that's that's probably
the biggest one so if your level my
whole leveling video just got a
wrench thrown into the middle of it
which sucks because i put that on
tuesday
not thinking this was going to be a
thing there's only so much i can do
no that's really cool i do like that i
know people laugh but i do like eight
modules because i'm an upgrade module
you are an upgrade
at the beginning of the season when
you're trying to level and you're
upgrading just look like trash for a
minute when you get up there then you
can don't spin an upgrade module make
this promise to me now do not spin an
upgrade module at least until level 1500
if you spend it in soft cap territory i
promise this
why why
it's just wasting
resources that i would be spending on
what
anything else i don't know but i i
literally said i need i need my 50 000
legendary shards that i
want to do
what are we horning them for
they are there to be used i didn't even
say the powerful cap i just said the
soft cap and you can't even give me that
one like everybody's listening to this
using rubbish weapons
really i it's so painful it's painful
you're going to be doing so much
you're going to use a blue shotgun
that's got we're going to be doing so
much crafting stuff it doesn't matter
i mean we'll see honestly dude crafting
might not be feasible early in the game
because there's they're adding 19
materials that i'm gonna have to grab
we've talked about we talked about that
cog by
a steak dinner it is not 19.
if you let me choose how you eat your
steak
let's take dinner
what if i win though
no no if you win you get a free steak
dinner but i get to decide how you eat
it
he gotta have a1 on his yeah you gotta
have flavoring on your steak
he's completely disgusting all things a
steak does not require much besides salt
pepper and a little bit of butter and if
you're gonna baste it a little bit of
time and garlic in that butter you don't
need a lot
i'm gonna put my old taco bell hot sauce
on your skin how's that sweet jesus
as well but look i'm with trav man like
you gotta understand like it's something
when you get the new campaign you get
the new dlc you know i said you're
playing you come across a cool whether
it be legendary or exotic weapon and
you're like man this feels good and you
know you're power leveling but it's like
i really gotta give this up right now
for this terrible blue
that i can't stand just for the sake
you're not even gonna you're not gonna
have a from up to the soft cap the
reason i said that is because that was
my joking moment because you guys can't
even embrace that one you're going to
get a drop literally every so often that
you're doing this you're not going to
have it long enough that it's going to
matter that's my point for the soft cap
true like when you got to powerful it's
going to go a little slower i get it
i'll i'll let you waste your resources
wherever you want yeah but like soft cap
yeah you're gonna have that you're gonna
you're gonna
like upgrade it every five seconds
you're gonna be out of upgrade modules
every mission probably
yeah
you're like oh i'm out of resources
do i need to ask why cog do i need to
ask why
like man i love them guns man i love
that but we'll move on we will fight
anywho
um but yeah that's the big one like if
you do all the missions on legendary you
can play legendary from the get-go
you can log in and play legendary that's
gonna be painful so they're gonna be
beautiful they're gonna have contests on
them so it doesn't really matter about
over leveling for them either
so all i can say is take arbalist in
there it's going to be your friend for
shields um
first unlocks on your artifact make sure
you got to bear make sure you got your
champions covered
yeah don't forget to get that catalyst
for our bless before it comes out too
all done baby
station yeah that's uh that's a word
to shift now yep sponsor's over advanced
cg is no longer sponsoring
hey i appreciate that i appreciate that
i hope you enjoy your new shakers sir
clearly oh that's amazing
what's the is that water or is there a
flavor in there mm-hmm
we doing the um
strawberry strawberry okay focus
strawberry travel danielle would be very
proud
shout out to a nice lady
what if he was just like it's chocolate
milk
i would just say hey throw some birthday
cake in there and then you got a dessert
awesome birthday bam it's actually
really good i've done that before
chocolate milk you're branded
i love it it's amazing i love it
chocolate milk is actually tasty though
and then no some people like what are
you a child i'm like no chocolate milk
is just good thank you yeah it is i love
chocolate milk but yeah they basically
say each mission is going to have a
power cap kind of like contest so you'll
be able to see like the highest level
that you're going to be able to go into
it but the big thing is you're going to
get more drops every chest like double
chest things like that and you can do it
from the start so here's the question
cog
you going normal are you jumping
straight legendary
normal
normal i don't want the pain part like
that man because i want to i want to go
in and get then flow back in there again
one and then think about you gotta have
to know what these encounters are
listen that's all you bro i'm gonna tell
you right now a wall are we studying we
studying each segment because you know
what they're gonna do track come on you
know they're gonna replace a couple of
witches and stuff and they're gonna put
champions in the spot they're gonna put
ogre so like they're gonna change
fundamentally i feel the encounter with
replacing it with like certain pain
point enemies that's my guess
you have to do something to distinguish
legendary yeah right now i mastered the
encounter right and i try to figure out
where to stand and what's going on then
i'm like all right now i'm a better idea
but y'all going in well y'all doing
legendary or oh yeah
don't say warlocks are studying when
you're playing on normal that's like
saying warlocks are studying but we're
reading from a first grade textbook you
know what i mean like he picked up his
little highlighting magazine at the
doctor's studies at college courses if
you want to if you want to brag about
the studying
he's got the highlights magazine at the
doctor's office doing the uh doing the
maze and the puzzles while y'all titans
banging your head against the wall
against the first little acolyte i will
be complete they leveled and come back
for more rewards while y'all still do it
we're uh we're getting our phd and ass
kicking erica
god bless i'm doing that dad yeah we
should do it together
we should do a fire team yeah we haven't
watched launch day we should play
through our legendary we have not done
that that is a fact and we should stream
it
that is why i will be streaming that's a
guarantee but you could go stream that's
right are you gonna be playing launch
day cog
the thing is but you know the rules
though here's the here's the issue the
issue is we've been around long enough
to know the server rules that day that's
what i mean that's what i'm wondering
about
yeah sorry maybe for the first hour or
two though there'll be a queue but yeah
right
get in look around do stuff but yeah no
i mean servers will be an issue
hope hopefully i mean they they've seen
the million pre-orders
we will have to see how the queue goes
but yeah you got the 14-hour
pre-download you guys aren't on
playstation so that's not an issue so
honestly
i mean just once we sit in the key off
[ __ ] are you i'm not taking launch day
off yeah what you're taking a wednesday
night no no i'm taking i'm taking you're
oh you're taking launch date i'm taking
the next i'm taking
day two when the servers are rough so we
need to get done with work
yeah that's why i was cause i figured i
said you come on traffic day one gonna
be crazy
the whole world [ __ ] my guests were
experiencing but i got a guy in the game
i don't have an option no you don't have
an option when i was playing this as a
player i would just play the next day or
whatever right i forgot
because i figured i was like this is
gonna be crazy that first day
take it off bro you work for a tech
company you must have unlimited vacation
there's no way that's paying you for
your days
[Laughter]
you should probably take less yeah yeah
such a trap dude it's such a trouble
i've been unlimited
for like a decade and i've never taken a
day off it's such a trap
okay well
uh tangent uh officially done so we're
back to void 3.0
okay
hunters
they're gonna be invisible all the time
that pretty much covers no i'm just
kidding
uh they will be though so like the
mobius quiver is gonna have two triple
shots out and that one's gonna actually
if they're attached by like mobius
quiver it's gonna cause them to be
volatile so then you can have them
explode chain explosions and that's
gonna happen
the other side of it which is the
deadfall anchors actually gonna have
more of a suction effect so you can get
the enemies in there
and then they have three aspects one of
these is just pvp forever i'm sure so
trapper's ambush player can activate
quick fall to spin their melee charge
and dive to the ground creating a smoke
cloud upon impact enemies caught in the
cloud are weakened and allies become
invisible in addition snare bombs upon
attaching to services caused nearby
allies to become invisible so that's
part of the invisible
vanishing step
dodging makes hunters invisible
that's just a boy that's just every pvp
hunter ever
dodge
invisible
go
did they get they dodged nerf recently
though a little bit
yeah they just think a little bit of
times they can do it
because they're freezing everyone yeah
they slowed it down a little bit i think
i don't know i haven't heard how bad
that is from a hundred's perspective if
anybody in chat
is a hunter
plays pvp like how is the hunter dodge
nerf for timing ben if you still specked
into it just let us know we don't play
hunter we're we're missing something in
the podcast sorry
stylish executioner defeating a void
debuff target weakened suppressed
volatile grants invisibility and true
sight
while invisible after a stylish
execution your next melee weakens
enemies
so they're really leaning into a couple
of these pairing together
like and you can just like cycle so for
the titans it's about getting the
overshield refreshing the overshield
hunters it feels like that invisibility
respect keeping that uptime going more
and more
and then the warlocks
you guys are just gonna be like devour
lethal
you guys are gonna suck to fight against
and pvp is gonna be real interesting so
you get a new melee
pocket singularity
fires an unstable ball avoid energy that
detonates when it nears enemies and
pushes them away from the blast making
them volatile
so picture a shotgun rusher now being
pocket singularity if you can time it
upright
then you get to hit them push them back
and if you kill them they're going to
explode
so double double wins
now you've got your nova warp super lets
warlocks quickly teleport from one spot
to the next and players can choose to
let loose with a deadly void eruption we
know about that with the vortex super
enhancement the nova bomb will now draw
enemies into your singularity
and then damage them once inside casting
a nova bomb casting a nova bomb with the
cataclysm enhancement will cause it to
travel slow as before and then split off
into projectiles
that's pretty standard but yeah your
vortex one is now going to have the
break bring into my vortex of doom
situation almost yeah like a dust feel
vibe
please put that back
for pve at least
pve that grenade is now just pointless
you're like oh cute they just like walk
through walk around you're like what are
you doing just know that that
if you don't like in pvp fine turn the
functionality back on in pve
just saying yeah i agree now here's
where you're gonna have some fun if you
haven't seen this stuff yet you are in
for a good time
your aspects are as follows chaos
accelerant
hold down the grenade button to
overcharge your vortex axiom bolts
scatter and magnetic grenades magnetic
grenades overcharge into handheld
supernova every class has every grenade
in case you didn't know
whoa whoa
warlocks that's crazy so magnetic
grenades overcharge into supernova yep
yeah that's the way they're giving
everybody yeah that's a handheld super
yeah so
that's how you're getting handheld
supernova and keeping it but you're also
getting every grenade so you have void
wall which you haven't had you never
have that yeah you have suppression but
know about that light suppression
grenade you're going to have that it's
going to be weird it's going to be super
weird delay yes wait
yeah
imagine a titan using like the
yeah it's gonna be weird we don't get to
charge it
is that not clear tight we don't get to
charge the grenades that is still a
warlock only thing so the magnetic
grenade is everyone but warlocks can
charge them correct that's right the
titans should keep the suppression
grenade this is offensive to me
everybody gets the grenades we all get
our little tweaks
um so feed the void defeat an enemy what
is the titan tweak then
like
we're leaning heavily into the
overshield stand behind a barricade get
an overshield
now the overshield can buff you for 10
seconds go back behind the the barricade
rebuff that overshield and get it again
so titans are leaning into the
overshield pretty sure the uh the
grenade
we're not getting any grenade
modifications but that's
again i get i get that but we're getting
different buffs
he's like we've been cheating hunters
hunters why the warlocks get back
hunters aren't getting if they're making
if they're making grenades ubiquitous
yeah but hunters hunter
a titan is not intelligent enough to
have too many crayons yeah we can't we
haven't read the text books the sacred
textbooks about the
about the handheld supernova abilities
anyway exactly so feed the void very
simple defeat an enemy with avoidability
and activate devour so if you defeat an
enemy with a void something you're going
to get devour active oh that doesn't
flow that's bottom tree that's the float
now there's an exotic that pairs with
this next one
and the void devourer i swear dev hour
is never going to turn off for you
child of the old gods cast your rift to
summon a void soul
when you damage an enemy with your
weapon your void soul will launch itself
towards the enemy
and detonate nearby attaching draining
tendrils which deal damage and weaken
the target so they take more damage
don't don't wait there's more
when your void soul deals damage it
restores either melee and grenade energy
when you're standing in a healing rift
or health if you're standing in an
empowering rift an empowering empowering
can heal you
defeating an enemy while who is being
drained grants rift energy so you can
start that cycle all over again
hold on
in case you didn't think it was good
enough there's an exotic that goes with
that
i gotta find the exotic where the hell
is the exotic
that's fine let me tell you right now
like
the hold on i got it okay why are you
doing that i got it i gotta get locks we
love we i call them the snitches anytime
you got snitches as a warlock
now you're telling me i can send them
out they're going to drain people i
could use it in power basically void now
has transformed like
significantly yes like that's an arc
play i used to play like that in with
arc like that's crazy
wow who's this designer hold on
here's your exotic yeah
i will say the exotics i feel like the
hundreds got the shaft on the exotics so
i will say travis in the grand scheme of
things he gets that we got some decent
exotics i think hunter's got the shaft
on the exotics we'll cover those i'm not
upset at all with what titans get it's
going to be all about overshielding yeah
okay so warlocks you're exotic which i'm
going way out of order but we just have
to do this all together so
cog can embrace this
um the new secant filaments with the
devouring rift perk
wait hold on
it's in exotic boots
oh we got bullets so we never get bigger
these shiny walking sticks of power will
grant a player devour when they cast
their empowering rift
oh wow
so now you cast your empowering rift you
have devoured wow what does it take to
get devour to stay up
just kill stuff right what does a
powergrip do makes you stronger
avoidability kills give you devour and
then you get health back and then you
get your rift energy back you have to
rift again and you're back in
oh it's all way to show me the picture
there let me have a big show it's on the
top it's towards the bottom of the
twelve bottles allowing for send pics
this is cogs uh yeah he's like
yeah
man i'm excited so yeah warlocks you're
gonna be just fine but it gets even
better the fragments which are
for all classes
uh the echo of expulsion you've got void
ability kills cause enemies to explode
that's actually going to lean more into
like the titan middle tree chain
explosions explode everything can't wait
for that
echo of provision damaging enemies with
grenades grant melee energy are you
looking at the boots right now those
boots on fire yo i got the outfit
already going with that i got my purp
always always lit i got outfit for that
continue hold on new red said go read
the rest of the boots description um
so grants you empowering rift allowing
allowing for damage from both allies and
individual players uh the ability to
disrupt foes but in style uh this
started as what
what can warlocks
what can we give warlocks that would
make empowering rift a more viable
choice in master plus content the answer
was well has to heal you right yeah
basically
no healing we're not interested yeah
we need i need i need my constant
band-aids to be put on me i just need
constant health packs please
yeah
yeah
so so eventually settled on devouring
rift pants overload was added to
increase excitement so yeah you're
pretty much good overload rift
those boots look so fun yeah we ain't
skipped leg day too i like these i like
these continue
anyway back to the fragments
damaging enemies with grenades grants
melee energy this is a strength penalty
this one just pisses me off and i know
it shouldn't but it's just like hey if
you do damage with a grenade you get
melee energy but we're gonna deduct from
your strength stat so your melee charge
is slower and i'm like
why
it reverses the exact thing it's
supposed to yeah exactly and it's
probably you should get more of a buff
than your little strength cooldown would
probably be but again still
do damage with a grenade you get melee
energy but we gotta make sure your melee
doesn't charge slower so we force you to
use grenades to get this thing that
doesn't recharge as fast i'm just like
take the last part off of there you were
good yeah leaning into the stasis
aspects
with um
there's a little give and take yeah it's
just i hate to take anyway yeah echoes
of domineering after suppressing a
target
greatly gain increased mobility for a
short duration and your equipped weapon
is reloaded from reserves so that's
basically suppress somebody they can't
do anything run up with a shotgun
probably blast them or
suppress a lucent brood and go crush
their ghost
that's where like i'm not even like
that's your life yeah y'all are
suppressors like let's be real like you
get to do that yeah
yeah like ne like to me one of the most
disrespectful thing is you fight a titan
and he throws that on he's like turn
your powers off shut up
like it's just weakening it's just like
very demoralizing so to have that like
i call it i call it the uh the fun
police and i love doing that titan fun
police is no longer exclusive to titans
the last one i'm definitely sad about
that because the fun police has been a
titan exclusive and it's also one of the
only things that's made the defender
tight and viable in pvp really i mean
the bubble is so situational it's not
really that useful but uh yeah that
grenade is a game changer can shut down
supers if you know how to use it it's
lethal and i'm i'm kind of i feel like
it makes the the titan void subclass a
lot less unique and interesting i kind
of agree i kind of agree
unless it's obviously i like that if
you're sure
but i do agree i feel it lou you guys
lose their identity because that is to
me a titan thing from the [ __ ] i feel
like they have to give us an exotic that
or or a perk or something exclusive that
allows our suppression to be a little
bit better than you guys just to as a
nod to its uh its origins as a titan
specific ability you know we need just
in the same way that you guys are
getting uh the ability to overcharge
magnet grenades yeah the handheld
supernova i think we need something that
allows us to do something special with
suppression grenades i don't know what
that looks like i agree i agree well the
last one in case you've been missing
oppressive darkness void grenades weaken
enemies
just straight up oppressive darkness for
a fragment like that's your pv that's
your pvp or pve perk right there
right there
so that's the big one uh they said like
the titan has several ways to earn and
extend its overshield use the bastion
aspect to create a barricade to grant an
overshield to you and your allies
throw the throne shield melee can grant
an overshield as does the void shoulder
charge so we can avoid shoulder charge
get an overshield drop a wall keep it up
buff it up like so that's why i was like
whirling in over shields hunters are
invisibility
you guys are just gonna heal devour
never die
yeah i got some flows maybe that's why
they made the hunter exotics not good
you don't really need an exotic if
you're just invisible the whole game
just stay invisible longer you you go do
that you just run run and rez the people
who die it kind of reminds me of d1 the
uh the ark subclass for hunters because
i remember they that's how people were
soloing raids back in that game as they
were just staying invisible like the
whole time yeah like they could stay
invisible for like minutes at a time
that was crazy yeah they're leaning into
it oh what yeah each aspects of of the
subclasses
yeah so i mean you've got that's most of
the recap i think that's everything
um so
new players
will start with a set abilities like
hunters are going to get mobius quiver
marksman's dodge triple junch snare bomb
and scatter grenade titans are going to
start with sentinel shield towering
barricade
catapult lift shield throw and magnetic
grenade warlocks are going to start with
nova bomb vortex healing rift burst glad
pocket singularity and vortex grenade
even the starting warlocks won that
battle but what
so how they doing because now this with
the void tree they're splitting up the
three
diamonds right they're just so it looks
like stasis yeah
right so with the super though for the
warlock i just have this question so
it's like
you can just like there's the big
diamond on the left right it's like you
can scroll below it and pick a different
one you can just pick your chapter oh
you just pick it right so but you guys
had a unique situation shout out to the
cops
separated yeah how are they gonna do
that for you guys it's the same thing
it's just separated so the titan bubble
is now its own super
and it's not going to be hold it's just
going to be click which also means now
the titan bubble is instant
so that's actually they even described
it for pvp you see somebody in the air
about to cast like blade barrage you can
actually get the super off in time to
take the blade barrage with the bubble
and survive as opposed to hold the butt
dead yeah you have to do that whole
because you guys will be captain america
first then transform into
got it so now that's an instant
and it's on the tier 5 recharge time
just as your well of radiance so it's
the fastest recharge super as well so
you get it more often
but yeah if you've been playing for a
while most everything is going to be
unlocked
except they they said
a few
aspects of like a few fragments or
something are going to come like after
the raid travis and i were joking there
might be a couple game breakers in there
of course but most thing when you log in
void is mostly going to be unlocked so
you don't have to go through this
lengthy process it seems like so that'll
be something just to clarify with but
most of it's going to be there so what
about
new lights
that's what the things i read off are
what new lights start with and then i
think new lights are going to work on
unlocking their void subclass direct
core is what i've heard yeah oh they
make her useful
yeah she's gonna be like well she's like
the main story beat it seems for witch
queen so we've also now got her piece of
the void subclass the weird part is
that's the first subclass they get
so they're gonna do the aspects and the
fragments and then they're gonna be like
all right now go with the other two mess
with the other solar and arc trees this
crap looks weird we're gonna fix this in
about six months
predictions who's going to be
the solar and arc
mpc vendor
um
uh arc will be
i was gonna say zavala but he always
pops a bubble
mm-hmm
anna bray should be arc
because she's a she's a hunter and she's
got like the ark stuff you know i'm
trying to think who's used solar
isn't the same insane saint would be
solar saint would be no um
saladin would be solid oh yes
or everything's going to go through icor
and it's not going to matter
yeah i should too no one else would yeah
that's just going to be your subclass
vendor
would you say characters we haven't met
yet
i should
and then when we get our next up no i'm
just kidding
kaido will be so
[Laughter]
calm
let me teach you what it means to be a
guardian
you disrespect my tank
[Laughter]
i love when she says that
you dare
they'll give you a hunter van garden
he'll do something finally now who knows
um i will say titans though that helmet
this uh the lorely splendor helm
more than just a pretty face that has
the cauterizing flame perk i run bottom
tree titan all the time so this one
speaks to me in so many ways
um
basically it says it allows for sunspots
to heal players when they have sun
warrior so the healing is actually a
nice thing critically wounded no big the
perk will ensure that a sunspot is
created in your location to give you one
last fighting chance with that perk and
grenade melee recharge
uh in supers plus more damage always a
good thing
and it just looks amazing it looks cool
as hell like that roman centurion type
joy like and i got like fire wings on my
head this is amazing
it's like like a fiery icarus kind of
vibe like it's crazy i go for like
that we got to give it up to know our
team and they always kill it oh that's
crazy
also the capture team apparently because
i saw one of the i guess it was like
artists or something like that they said
thank you for making my creation look
absolutely amazing from like the capture
team so apparently they place it in the
picture wherever it is in the world they
probably just put the thing on the
ground and move the camera but yeah the
capture team taking these pictures
apparently doing pretty good
um so we've got the horror frost chest
that's the
uh big glacial wall that we've seen but
it's also gonna work for benefits of
basically like one of the best
barricades you can have it's still got
the little window to shoot between i
like that if if things get close to you
you're you're going to get you're going
to slow things near the barricade
and then it's also going to boost weapon
reload stability and range sounds a lot
more like
that sounds like kind of empowering
range boost but now you've got reload
speed stability and range with that ice
wall ice wall i hate the the titan super
but that ice wall is definitely
something somebody on your team can put
down and lots of benefit from
yeah like if somebody destroys your
destroys your ice yeah and then it goes
away
yeah yeah well hopefully not
you have the best boots ever so you just
warlock rift for
uh
all those things you've also got some
gauntlets
so those are going to be fun the
osteomancy gauntlets those are the
furvid cold snap perks you get double
cold snaps with faster recharge
uh oh no hold on you get double cold
snap grenades they have enhanced seeking
and they travel farther but it also says
it will recharge faster when it makes
direct impact
so i don't know if you hit him with it
and then it like tracks or does what
it's going to do you actually get faster
recharge from it so good luck being
accurate
yeah that's okay i mean anything with
two is cool but i don't know if i'm
really gonna lean into that but it's all
right it's basically you know those
those specific class specific type
exotics
and then the final ones for the hunter
so we've got the voltaic mirror that
basically allows the arc staff to have
increased damage for what you reflect it
also seems like you're going to get more
orbs of power from it that's the one we
saw in the trailer it's like it's fine
and then the gauntlets also have the
renewal grasp
so that's going to basically allow the
dust field grenade to be bigger this is
actually kind of a support one which is
kind of cool to see
uh so it gives guardians a much larger
radius for their dustfield grenades
while also nerfing incoming damage for
all allies within the duskfield grenade
any targets locked within the space will
also deal a reduced amount of damage so
go out there and make the hive cry so
it's almost like a
bubble you can stand in less incoming
um
yeah less incoming damage and then they
do less outgoing damage if they're in it
too so it's really going to allow you to
kind of almost throw that bubble at your
feet for more of a defensive situation
which is kind of it's a unique one i
don't know how to play in support but it
does give stasis hunters some support
yeah
i feel that the hunters didn't get the
good end of the stick out of this though
yeah i do feel the exotics for the other
two are pretty fire especially like
yours and then our fire helm and then
all of a sudden yeah i don't think
hunters won this one yeah
poor went out for the hunter exotics
this time
oh well
uh they did reiterate the downtime
you've got 14 hours of server downtime
on the 21st at 7 p.m pacific
the pre-load if you are on playstation
longest uh destiny's ever been down
i don't know if it's the longest cause i
feel like we had 14 or 15 hours for
something else too because i feel like
we've had down time for something
i can't remember what was there down
time before beyond light when like the
arrival darkness crept into the director
and they kind of like kicked us out i
think it was like six to eight hours and
they finished it early i don't think it
was this long
but i don't know if they would have done
i don't know if they do server downtime
and there was like an event at the end
of season of arrivals was it a rivals
before beyond light they wouldn't do it
at like two o'clock in the morning for
like six or eight hours they would do it
the evening before so i feel like it's
been similar
last time was
so just my guess but again if you're on
playstation
make sure you start your preload and
also before the time is up you need to
download um compatibility packs as well
so once the hotfix has been applied
basically once which queen is on yours
you need to boot it up try and log in
and then it's going to download the
compatibility pack so just want to get
that out there yeah playstation on day
one doing this
this we know what's about to happen no i
mean you can get the patch servers we
know there's going to be queues but
you'll you need to get the patch
beforehand is all i'm trying to say
for sure uh but other than that i mean
you got artists and movies of the week
and all that fun stuff next week we know
they are going to cover
gambit so it's going to be a light
lighter swab and gambit next week i
joked like four weeks ago that they were
gonna save gambit for last and they
actually are saving gamut for last i'm
i'm blown away they do mention they said
uh gambit details coming next week i
want to set expectations the team is not
tearing down and rebuilding the mode
from the ground up the team will
illustrate goals and walk through some
changes we hope to improve the mode
while addressing player feedback
basically it probably will be a lighter
top twab touching on stuff like that
and then at some point we're probably
going to get giant patch notes as well
but that'll i don't know if that's going
to be on server day
so we the thought process that we're
going to talk about what we're going to
do forgive it or what is going to be
done for gambling what's going to be
done for gambit it sounds like i think
it's what's going to be done i think i
think they're changing stuff in which
yeah like i think witch queen is
may not be a big rework but it's a
rework of gambit even if it is smaller
otherwise cog why would they talk about
it before between launches yeah
if they if if they were just telling us
our plans like they did with that would
be later right that's what i was worried
about yeah yeah i just i think they're
changing stuff and they're like hey we
want you to tell about tell you about it
now so that it's not a surprise when
which queen drops and there's some
changes to gambit but i'd be surprised
if they were like super substantial
they're definitely not going to save
that broken mode
i don't know what they like if they're
obviously i don't expect massive massive
changes if they change like invader
timing if you spawn
the what the hell is the enemy at the
end of goomba that's how often i play
this thing i don't even know
if you spawn the prime evil your invades
should stop until the other person does
those are the types of tweaks that i
would see
i know i think i saw somewhere and i
don't know if this is i've seen it
somewhere the gambit trait
i think is invader tracking
like your gambit weapons have invader
tracking so if you can actually either
tag or track i don't know if it's gonna
like see through or if it's gonna be put
the little arrow on the head or whatever
but if you can tag an invader and then
they can't get away there's incentive to
use gambit weapons in that mode in
theory and that's also gonna be one of
the first uh cosmetic
things for weapon crafting is going to
come from gambit they said the raid they
said grand masters trials stuff like
that will probably have it later but
gambit will have the first
crafting cosmetic situation they did
mention they want you to play gambit
they're going to give you a reason
of course of course we know the vibes
but yeah i think that is
i think that's most somehow it blew
through a lot of information um i've
covered a lot of stuff in the videos
they did also have the interactive
trailer today i don't know if you had a
chance to look at that cog
basically
so you should definitely check it out
it's just a cool history of like the
hive and savathun kind of gives people a
chance to catch up in how we are where
we are here how we are here now
so it's a cool way to go through the
history they talk about fundament
um they go back that far so they really
go through
kind of the history the reason why the
scarlet keep was created i mean they
they go through savathun's motivations
for just about everything she's been
through it's actually really cool to get
that much history if you haven't watched
the biff video you've probably never
even heard the word fundament with
related destiny so it is cool to see
that referenced
first time
um let's see
what about you cog
anything that you've heard thought
otherwise that we haven't touched on
that maybe you wanted to talk about that
you don't know if we did or not
no i just think that um
they've got a lot packed in i i i am
warming up i think right now my
excitement is actually poor
43.00 than anything which is weird
which is weird like i think it's gonna
be really weird
is looking at the
solar and arc subclasses yeah with the
face down
that's gonna be really weird because
right now at least there's a separation
when you toggle between darkness and
light but now it's gonna be like what's
especially if you're a new player you're
gonna be like why are these other
subclasses so different yeah yeah that's
one of those like kind of budgetary
budgetary things you kind of wish it was
all at once yeah
i mean it gives you something to look
forward to in the new seasons but right
now it's like hey void's cool it's like
okay now you've got redheaded step
children of subclasses over here
it's just like
and one of them is going to be six
months away oh yeah for sure for sure
it's the right call it's the right call
and that's i i just love
that customers it's an enhanced version
of what d1 was trying to do you know
what i'm saying and i like the the
customization i like a lot of the
synergies that's honestly the most
the the the crafty stuff until i get it
in my hand not that i'm like a po i just
need to get it in my hand before i can
see yo this is it they did it like i
just need to see that but um
i'm ready man i'm ready campaign you
know what i'm saying i'm ready
yeah i got all my stuff done a month ago
because i'm ready to do this i'm ready
now yeah i'm ready i'm like let's get it
i want to see the secrets and i like
that whole deep side i like that playing
into the deception aspect of savithoon
that's really cool
and i'm hope my hope is
for um
like a better what was uh taking what
was dreadnought like i'm hoping for like
a a better dreadnock experience but also
i want to see
how they handle that transition
post-throne world what are they holding
on to if if anything you know is is
there something else
that's the thing i wonder it's like
we're adding a destination
and it's a representation of savings
mind that's her throne world
they don't put a destination to get rid
of it at the end of a campaign this
thing's staying here which is another
implication that i think seven is not
going anywhere but yeah it's like this
is a destination that they just put in
we got europa that's not going anywhere
obviously it's a new destination they
made some engine tweaks and stuff like
that um so it's going to be in the game
for a while that makes me wonder
how does the story of savithoon play out
because if if we defeat savithoon
there shouldn't be a throne world in
theory is that wrong is that right chat
do you have any idea
like does that mean she's not going
anywhere till the inevitable end of the
game end of the
stuff
am i probably breaking some people who
are questioning my lore questions i
don't know i'm just wondering like
that's more the question of like the
long-term piece of this right is
i very have more of a role to play
beyond this yeah expansion yeah
yeah
very complex they've been very uh
good about keeping villains around
whether it's uh
you know kaidal and
you know they're not really good at
doing it in their main expansions but so
far they've kept people around and found
new uses for them so
have we got any word about uh the homie
mythrax is anyone seen him
he's one of our allies no
where's the house of of light where they
at he's hanging out in the fallen
quarter right
he's got a raid
he's just running he's running the
scorching pass by himself yes
interesting i'm very curious with him
too and the crow advancement what is
going to happen yeah
he's going to be part of the season
so we know he's part of the season of
the risen because he's hanging with
kaido which is cool to see him put back
in which i'm glad because at the end of
the season he's just going to go off and
hang out and we're jumping back in with
him again which i'm happy to see as well
so no we got kaidal we got crow back
we have all the npcs in one room for
some crazy cinematic we know i like that
and then i just got to know what happens
with seventh hoon and i want to
understand the raid the story connection
to the raids
has to be like it's got to be epic
1 000 that's what i want to know because
this
this is this is savage man so i mean i
know that's probably most likely not
gonna be the vibe of getting now it's
like it's probably not gonna be a taking
king thing because it doesn't seem it's
just ancient evil right so this is
something else and we maybe what if we
get the
the race the other the other
i think travis's review just dropped by
three points yeah
that would be really tough you can't
give a game a bad review because they
use tanix as a boss again
but you can definitely talk about it for
four paragraphs
and and just really question the
storytelling chops
i'm still hopeful that the thing they're
holding on to i think at this point i've
kind of given up on them holding out for
a secret subclass in the uh
what is it the poison subclass even
though all the evidence is like pointing
to no i think it's something they wanted
to
yeah but i don't think they could build
it balance it and i think stasis scared
them
because it came out so busted they had
to nerf it four times still was like all
of those things i think that scared them
so much and they had to take so much
time trying to fix that
yeah they could do some tweaks to the
ones we have existing and then they're
probably gonna give another year before
we get it i do think we're gonna get
another one i think it's just gonna be
with lightfall yeah i think we'll get
two more and uh but yeah anyway i i've
sort of given up on that theory but i
still am holding out hope that we will
meet the uh the people that are running
the black fleet um i do yeah i in some
context maybe the final boss or
the final encounter i think there's
going to be some sort of like yeah
yeah we've had we've had the darkness
veil things referenced in garden of
salvation garden yeah yeah and then
of course now with the darkness and the
pyramid ships with all the stasis stuff
that we went through also dudes done
crypt
yeah deep stone crypt as well so it's
like multiple raids the whole thing
about the darkness the pyramid ships
came on screen at some point that's got
to pay off like this is the yes this is
a very long game of destiny that if
you're not around for all of it it does
take a while for some of these things to
pay off because this one definitely
seems about savithoon
and again either we're assembling the
adventures of the alien species of saul
or who knows what's gonna happen i don't
know but before we go sir i did want to
ask you
how's sifu
oh that's fine oh my lord i love it i
absolutely love it
i am very early probably beat the dude
that killed me
as a kid the early dude and then i'm up
to just like the the club or whatever
yeah but um yeah that thing
that is so see like you know you're the
dark souls dudes i get it yeah
this is how you trick me
to get this ain't even no type of soul
stuff but i just love the fact that
one
that mechanic with the aging is really
cool because like if you get older then
you kind of become like a glass cannon
but you hit harder yeah i do like that i
do like the fact that as you progress
and level you basically whatever level
you get at your youngest age you know
what i'm saying it kind of retains that
but it's just
as an older gentleman
what i love about it is these are the
kind of movies that me kings solve with
bodies kung fu flicks it's always the
same trope right yeah the evil bastard
comes in he murders
you know the father or the master he
doing something for evil and then the
kid is either spared or whatever and
then you start the training in the
process to go and like this is the
essence of kung fu flicks at its core
like this is how you trick me
into these type of ga and it's not
really like super difficult it's just
that
i love what they're doing i just wish
i was gonna say uh hold your thought on
that one i will say this
i hope
they my only nitpick is that i love it
so much i just feel there should be more
of that cinematic flair with narrative
and i'm hoping just because they don't
worry
okay i'm gonna get it i'm gonna get it
okay world two starts it
world three
you'll you'll see what they're doing
with the levels
okay okay
the levels change kind of a game
um
three does some things when you're like
oh oh oh like
you'll see some stuff which is fair
enough which is enjoyable yeah
but yeah when you get the when you get
to three
and you've seen most of the world of
three i want you to text me so i know
you've what you've seen let's see i fed
up yeah what i would say is that i just
want this game to succeed because
if they have a triple a budget
oh it's on it so they're really punching
above their weight with what they've
done so far and i i like it so i want to
salute those guys did uh i believe
absolver yep or whatever and um i like
the art style it's just you're gonna
love it even more by the time you get
farther on i'm telling you bro you know
when they had me early
when you do the hallway and it was like
the dead it went sideways dude that was
so good
i said this is for me and then you you
be i took a snapshot of all the body's
bodies
i think i was age 23.
you haven't even played it yet
i know i got a call i was like
i'm on the final boss rook's in the
final boss we've been trading back and
forth a maze though
pretty sure he's almost like
like
flawlessing this damn game
i i caught him and i rated him because i
was playing i was like who's playing
he's playing sifu
dude's near the end
like 21 years old
just like absolutely just mad mad man
just absolutely killing it
see that's what i want to get what do
you i will say that game i do want to
get nice it is it is a game about
mastery that is what it is
i want to master the standstill the
dodge as opposed to the parry so that
cause you whit they make them whiff get
the focus yep there's a lot to it
there's a lot to it man
fighting game fans stand up i feel you
don't mind shout out to voidlock spartan
with the super chat two dollars uh we
absorb her worm for a new subclass in
2023.
i'm down that would be that would be a
way to go to the dark side that would
probably be hard to come back from but
hey light fault there you go it just
sold itself we're good
i like it
well thank you cog for joining us
appreciate it for me thank you for
waiting for me next week you can take a
nap after this who wants to announce our
guest next week because you all know who
it is
oh yeah
cog you wanna you wanna drum
listen man it's one of my favorites it's
one of my favorites one of the smooth
actually i think
i think me and teddy had this
conversation
loki doesn't get credit it's probably
one of the funniest content creators
like absolutely hilarious he's very good
at his writing yeah when you could do a
man skate commercial and have me like
erupt into laughter every time
he's just hilarious it's the hobby man
to fall out bro fall out please let's go
yes so fallout will be joining us next
week i don't know if we're going to get
him for much more than an hour so we
will have to be kind of succinct with
that one
but
um
yeah fallout plays will be joining us
next week same time same bat channel so
we will be here same time same place no
weird morning or anything like that so
it will be the 17th if i can do math
correctly 7 p.m fallout plays joining us
we're basically gonna have all the
information for which queens so we're
just gonna jump in
and see
talk about gambit
we're gonna be the gambit exclusive show
yes it's gonna be gambit fallout's
favorite topic i'm sure
um but honestly shout out to
fallout shout out to uh mercury's as
well over on dcp right now they've got
kevin yawn is yeah shout out to
mercury's first he had chris proctor on
massive breakdown excellent listen and
then right now as we're wrapping up this
show dcp is kicking into their piece
they've got kevin giannis and one other
gentleman from bungie i just remember
kevin so i'm sorry the other guy we i i
forgot to look but they have two bungee
guys on there talking and then it's
fallout mercury's and the dcp crew
talking to a couple of bungee guys
tonight so if you want any more
information a lot of information dropped
this week i'm going to give that a
listen to see what other nuggets because
they always tend to i will say chris
proctor in the interviews
will tend to give probably a little more
than you'd expect but it's been like i
mean he's mostly just given like nuggets
about like weapon archetypes and things
but he'll just give some information
you're like oh there's like 50 weapons
and you're like i'm sorry you play what
yeah that was one of the things that i
saw come out from when chris proctor was
um
with mercury's he's like yeah there's
like 42
and then the vidoc it was like 50 but
now those those are some good listens
when they get a chance to talk with
those guys so just wanted to drop that
one so when we are done with our podcast
which i do believe there's a good amount
of you watching shout out to all 120 you
guys thank you for the super chats thank
you cog for making that my advice is
please go to twitch.tv
slash dcp live uh i think it's dcp live
or dcb underscore live go check out that
one
shouldn't be too far in the middle of it
so that is gonna be a good list and i
will listen to it so i advise checking
it out they're a hilarious crew so oh
yeah for sure
uh but gentlemen as we wrap this thing
up travis what awesome get you didn't
hear him talk about crossfire x by the
way
i missed that and i did want to hear
that tell him please yeah briefly can i
get there
it is one of the worst games i've ever
played
it's unbearable
no
it
the main menu doesn't even run stable
the main menu glitches out and and has
frame drops and crashes
uh
the it has one of the most disgusting
microtransaction models ever where you
can buy more powerful weapons to help
you in the game uh it uh
the the the multiplayer modes are
incredibly ill conceived like you'll
you'll just like spawn in the same area
your entire team will spawn in the same
area so the opposite team can just stand
at your spawn point and just like mow
you down
um there's an infection mode where the
you know the zombies are coming for you
and if they hit you once you become a
zombie right you become like an alien uh
except for the aliens have like
you have to shoot them 20 times to kill
them and they only have to hit you once
to transform you and so it's impossible
to win as the humans
but it also doesn't matter because as
soon as you become infected you join the
infected team so you're always on the
winning side
it doesn't make any sense like just
every part of the game is poorly thought
out and then the campaign is really not
much better it's it's slightly better
because it's made by remedy and i guess
it's a different engine but it has the
same kind of problems and it it's just a
nightmare dude i i
i'm
this is why i was telling i was telling
you this this is why uh
game critics are always so wary of games
that that don't have early access copies
because yeah i think i think i think
everyone involved in this project knew
that they had created a dud and i think
that they tried their best to hold the
line and obscure that fact into the very
end and uh yeah dude it's
i don't know i have no idea what i'm
going to review it but it it's it is a
bad game i was going to say don't mask
the truth says he would give it an ign
6.5 out of 10.
that's insane a 6.5 would be like okay
almost good so you're leaning more like
three or four right now it feels like
yeah it's it's it's four at the most it
is at the very least a bad game yeah and
and uh a three at ign means
awful
a two means
painful and a one means unbearable so
it's somewhere in that range i i don't
think it's a one quite frankly but it's
it's certainly no nothing higher than a
four uh just based on what i've played
uh do not play that game
it's not even worth the download on game
pass honestly it's not uh also
it's in game pass it's in game pass but
not the story the story mode is good
story and that's really all anybody
wants to play yeah but honestly the
multiplayer is not worth your time i do
not recommend it and that's crazy last
question is wasn't this game because me
and maddie it's funny you said that as
me and maddie we did do because we were
like they got to be hiding something
like you can't get any information on it
but i heard that like it was like big in
china like this game is huge
somewhere else it had a pc release the
other crossfire game and it's sort of
like a
uh a a cs go a counter strike sort of
like clone and it gained some some
love there but uh this port is on xbox
and pc and in both places it's really
bad i was telling e i think the problem
cog is that they had so many different
developers working on the game yes and
then they put it into one game and i
think it had a master chief collection
effect where
all these games all working on one
software and out of one menu just
screwed everything up but even then
there are still game design problems
that are super questionable like they
did not test it at all like the spawn
the spawn situation is just horrible
like every part of the game makes you
question if like if they put any time
into developing it's just so it's so
bizarre man okay final thing travis for
your outro i know you got other stuff
going you are going to be reviewing no
it's
um
no other words besides the numerical ign
score for season one of boba fett
boba fett why do i say that wrong now
boba fett six okay
okay there you go all right now you can
do your outro
yeah i i
i wanna like that show but it was very
inconsistent in its quality uh but yeah
it's still more star wars i love it i i
watched the whole okay yeah watch it in
a couple months but
if i'm being objective it was just an
okay show
anyway uh yeah um so i did a ton of
stuff in the past couple weeks uh my
review of dying light 2 is out if you
care about that i'm also working on the
dying light to wiki for ign so if you're
playing dying light 2 it's going to be a
minute to use uh the interactive maps
and some of the guides that we're
creating i'm helping out with that nice
i also
uh did a review of far cry 6's dlc uh
which is called collapse it's one of the
three dlcs i gave that a five out of ten
i don't recommend really playing it it's
it's kind of not great um
and then uh i also
did a preview of assassin creed's new
um expansion called dawn of ragnarok
which uh really looks like it's gonna be
a lot of fun that's coming out in march
if you have time for it um if you're
like me and and thought valhalla was a
little bit boring and a little bit too
big to get through this looks like the
exact opposite it's basically standalone
it has its own side map and you play
odin you play odin the god and you have
a whole bunch of superpowers and you can
shoot lightning it's sweet um i might be
it on this when you almost named my
preview
uh
in dawn of ragnarok you can turn into a
bird
and then assassinate someone so you can
fly around as a bird and then hit the
assassinate button and your bird will
dive in and then at the last second you
turn back into a human and you you
assassinate well i was wondering if you
were gonna like peregrine falcon 2 and
like dive and kill him as a bird just
like impale with the beak or something
yeah you turn into you turn into a uh
into a human again at the last second
but it's real it looks really cool it's
got just a whole bunch of weird powers
and you know the the assassin's creed uh
has been a little bit stale so it's cool
to see them trying new stuff i think uh
all right let's try it try new stuff
um
so yeah i did all that stuff and then
this week i'm reviewing crossfire x so
i'm actually doing two separate reviews
one for single player one for
multiplayer so both of them are gonna
get fours
yeah so you can look for that um
um online uh next week but yeah i'm
working on a ton of content for ign this
month and then my next review after
crossfire x unless unless any more
surprise reviews pop up is going to be
a little game called destiny 2 the witch
queen so
i'm very excited to review that game and
uh i'll be i'll be posting my thoughts
online maybe review in progress and then
my final review will come out the day
after the raid um i'm going to be
streaming my raid with d flawless
so you can watch you can watch us make
jokes while we bang our head against the
wall trying to kill 7th dune or whatever
pretty nice it should be i'm having a
really fun month guys this is that's
what's up yeah you've been killing it
man you've been killing it man the dying
light all this stuff man then now
destiny did
not stop brother keep it up keep it up
loving to work cog what about you and
the metaverse
so much um other than that yeah it's
been whatever you see oh duke i gotta we
did a great like i highly
recommend if you can
watch um duke ultimate we did an xbox
one retrospective that was fun as hell
kick david's on it
nice it is abs but it it it's actually
like
we really hit it from all angles yeah it
was such a polarizing generation but we
break it down all aspects of it you know
so we got that going on being that
maddie came back we did duke and then um
supposed to have a guest on sunday's iop
so we'll see what hap might be a little
different from the norm we're gonna do
something a little different but it's
still gaming related so we're gonna ask
him offline because i don't know what
the hell he's talking about
yeah yeah
we would do something different but yeah
so they should be fun
and yeah man like just been just been
catching up just trying to get through
man super bowls this week so it's big
busy busy week for me work wise but
other than that i am glad at least i
could make it here because when i saw
this i was like oh man there's so much
good destiny stuff to talk about i'm
like i gotta work no
so i am glad i'm here but yeah you got
to get back with the whole beast because
it was a struggle i needed this yeah i
needed to just talk about games and fun
no stress oh yeah salute
and e what about you with your uh
amazing advanced gg shaker that i have
now
a proud owner you know what's funny it
shipped today i was like oh like that's
another i gotta make it even if i'm late
because i got a big that's what she
delivered today yeah shout out to uh use
code ibantus at advancefug.com
links are plastered all over my social
you guys know where to find me of course
no just kidding
but seriously
we seriously use it use the damn code
use dave cole buying use the guide
um
no honestly if you just have if you ever
have questions about it let me know
that's all i'll say
i
i use it
that's pretty obvious but if you ever
have questions i'm happy to answer them
uh but outside of that yeah i'm trying
to beat sifu literally on the final boss
i don't know if i'm gonna go for like in
a maze like trying to beat the whole
damn thing undefeated
that's probably a little extreme because
there's some parts where it's just like
if i beat it i'm in a decent age when i
get through it i'm kind of good
uh but rook actually in chat he and i
have both been playing it kind of
trading who's ahead of who so it's been
pretty fun
uh lost ark have also been playing so if
i get any time kind of like level 19 of
that my friend has left me in the dust
but that's not surprising because that's
all he's been playing
uh and then yeah witch queen i'm trying
to keep up with all the news i literally
made a video
my video on tuesday was about the
viaduct we knew that was going to happen
that was long wednesday i have my
leveling guide for witch queen if you
guys are curious about that one outside
of now going for your legendary
um campaign clear because that will make
a big jump in your powerful and
pinnacles on that first character and
all the characters um that video went up
and then they dropped void 3.0 i'm like
oh god because i figured that would be
in the twab but that was long enough
that they made it separate and then
today we had an interactive trailer so i
made a video and then a 12 video then we
observed i'm just running out of space
so
i'm busy we're busy we're all busy but
mine is very destiny related but my
variety content is keeping me sane see
if it was a blast i want to smash it and
then move on so it's fun though it's
really really fun and when you get to
the third level and you get toward when
you get to the end of the third level i
need i need to text i don't care the
hours like we can be like holy hell this
is all like that's what i want to say
no doubt i can't wait man love it
well gentlemen
all of chats all of you guys that have
been out there for pretty much the
entire episode thank you guys so much i
know cog wasn't here at the start but we
did get him in so i thank you all for
hanging in till he got here so we can
get the
ninja's opinions about all the good
things
the
best dressed man with the tailored suits
that's a man about his business
right here
inside of the breast pocket that man is
monogrammed yep
that man's got it covered so
uh for everybody thank you so much for
being here we will see you tomorrow same
time same bat channel with fallout plays
do not miss this one we gonna have a
good time in that one but for this
episode number 184
february 10th we are not far from witch
queen we have 12 days
so for this episode it has been